よろしくお願いします
えっと 今日は話早く終わると思います
えっと あんまり内容は難しくもないと思います
この怒りを切り崩せということで
この 神々の王になった男の七つの誓いと読む
七つの誓いということで
で この神々の王っていうのは
この まあインド文化の
まあお釈迦様以前からね
インド人が一般的に信仰していた神だとは思いますね
まあはっきりしないんですからね
インドの神々のエピソードっていうのは
どうもこの曖昧ではっきりしないんですね
突然性格が変わって別なものになるんですから
どうせ人間が作る物語ですからね
まあいろいろ勝手にいろんな地方の物語がダブってしまっちゃって
まあそれぞれで乗り移ってしまうこともありますからね
ある地方である神の概念が考えたところで
そこは他の地方に行ったら
その地方に元々あった神の考え方に乗り移ってしまう
乗り移してしまうということもあります
で この文学的に歴史をたどったっても
大した意味が出てこないんですね
インド文学ではこのヴェーダ聖典というのは一番古いと思ってるし
文学的には古いんで 残っている文学としては
だからといって テキストにならなかったんだからといって
インドでは他の文学は文学はなかったわけでもないし
それであのヴェーダ聖典で
この このアーリア民族がこの騎馬民族で
いろんなところに戦って戦争して出ていくんですね
だからまあおそらくイランとか
もうそこら辺ね 中央ヨーロッパ
ヨーロッパまでないんですよ
イランとかね そこら辺ですね
この今の  中央ロシアに入ってるね
まあところの中央のところとか
そういういろいろなところから
このアーリア民族がこの西に東に広げてしまっちゃって
で 当時であった文明はほとんど破壊しちゃったんですね
だからそれでアフガニスタン
パキスタンとしてインドに入るんですよ
それでまあ このそちらにあった古い古代文明は全部ね
片っ端から壊されちゃって
で 戦って戦って進んでいったんです
そこでまあ一番ありがたい神として拝んでいたのは
このインドラ という神なんですね
インドラっていうのは
まあ戦いの神でもありながら
王様という意味でもあります
今も我々の言語では まあインドラ
インドラっていうのはまあおという意味なんですね
で まあまあ 普通人間の名前にも使ってますからね
まあそんなごく一般的な単語なんです
人の名前をつける場合は
日本でね まあ何々郎とかね
太郎とかねという男って意味の漢字を入れたりするでしょ
まあそんな感じで インドラっていうところは名前にあげに帯に
まあ帯につけたりはします
だからすごい一般的になってますけど
まあ初めの時代って考えると
まあその紀元前もっと古いからね
当時でこのアーリア民族がね
まあ戦略してきた時の彼らの神なんですね
彼らがまあ人殺しだけで
そんなに大した文化を持っていたかどうかはわかりませんだけど
一応神には祈りをする
戦争ですからね まあ生贄もする
神を賛嘆しながら前に行くというね
そこでモヘンジョダロという古代文明
ハラッパっていうところにあった古代文明っていうのはもう片っ端から壊しちゃって
どうなったのかと まだもうわからないし
発掘したってもよくわかる
あんまりにも優れた文明で
それですごい幸いなことに
その両方もうイスラム人にやられちゃったんだから
もう ぱしから壊すんです
古いものは 考古学なんかはコーランではなんか禁止みたいですね
神だけ真理ですからね
古いものはすべて壊しなさいということで
で だからまあ研究は無理
立ち入り禁止 で この紀元前 3年
3000年の古いレンガを持っていて
便所を作ったりするんです
大量にありますからね
で そんなもんで仏教もありましたからね
もうかなり昔からもね
だから仏像でもすごい古いものも見つけたら 2つに割るんです
首は首で割って 体はものすごい金額で売って
首は別にまた同じ金額で売る
で 仏像は売りますね 売れますからね
他はまあ潰すんです だから考古学的に見れば
もう値段つけられないぐらい価値があるものなんですけどね
まあとにかくまあ アーリア民族も同じことをやっちゃってね
まあインドまで行って
南までは行かなかったんですけど
まあとにかくこの古代文明の人々が
インド人人々はいたんだけど
どうかで気が弱いんですね
まあ文明発達すると一応それが出てきますから
この戦争と文明っていうのは一致しないんだからね
だから文明が発達したっていうことは
戦争しないっていうこと
平和でいるっていうことなんですね
だからモヘンジョダロっていうのは
もう恐ろしい文明が発達していたっていうことは
それは古代文明の一つで
まああまり戦わないんですね
まあそういう人々は まあこう
文学やら踊りやら宗教やら農業やらね
そういうものばっかりやって贅沢に生活しているんですね
だからこの一番学者ぶってびっくりするのは
このモヘンジョダロなんかであったこの水道システムなんですね
街を作ったら水はどうするのかと
ちゃんと水が流れるように下水管も作ったりして
で 水道があったんですね
だから インド人になった方が便所もない文明になったんだからね
水道のところがもうガクンと落ちたんで
いまだに立ち上がってないんですよ
いろいろあちらこちらですごいものあるんだけどね
一般的にも基本的に均等
均等的に発達していないんですね
で そういうこのアーリア民族がインドに入ったのは入ったんだけど
それからどうするのかっていう知識はなかったんです
だから結局 自分たちが野蛮人だと思った人々の知恵を借りなくてはいけなくなっちゃったんです
どう政治するのか どう管理するのかと
それでインドにアーリア民族が入ったら特別な文化になってしまったんですね
そこでアーリア民族は自分たちが神に祈りしていたんだから
一部の人々はね そこはもうバラモンカーストやったりしてね
で 管理する連中がね シャトゥヤという名前で
その他の人々はワイシャというね
まあいろいろカーストですね
ワイシャの意味は まあいろいろな人がいるんだと
そこでまあ奴隷がいてね
奴隷というのは西洋的な奴隷じゃないんです
ただ召使いカーストなんです
で それが別に人権侵害ということにはならないんですけど
まあ人に雇われて仕事をするということは
私たちもほかの国でやってますからね
人に雇ってもらってね
それが別に何だいっていうよね
それにヨーロッパ人にいちいち言われる権利はないんですけどね
まあ例えば家政婦って仕事あるでしょ
それって卑しい仕事ですかね
でも人に雇われているし
まあこれはインド的に見れば召使いカーストなんです
だからカーストというのはおかしいんですけど
まあだから仕事は昔も今も変わってないんですね
そういうことで この人に雇われて仕事をする人々がシュードラというね
この意味はわからないんですね
ワイシャは一応意味はわかりますけど
シュードラって このドラっていうのは
まあなんかインドラの場合は神って王っていう意味になっちゃうしね
このいいに対する主なんでしょう
はあんまり悪い意味も持ってないしね
意味がわからないんですね
だから誰も意味を探そうとしていないみたい
昔から知ってる単語だからね
うん  そこで インド独特な文化文明が発達していくんですね
そこはこのアーリア人の純正な文化っていうわけじゃなくて
これはカルチャラルアマルガムといってね
もうもう合体するんですね
だから西洋文化とはね
まあ結構違うというか
同じ民族なんですけど
文化文明が変わっていくんですね
で それで宗教は結構 発達したんですね
だから宗教は結構ありましたから
それで問題はこの アーリア人に占領される以前のあらゆる神々が信仰していたんだから
畑の神 水の神 風の神とかね
いろいろいたんですね
瞑想もしていたんですね
その連中は いろいろありましたから
アーリア民族には大した宗教はなかったし
で そこでまあいくつかの伝統の宗教が現れたんですね
まあとにかく支配層カーストですから
まあこちらは力強くて
自分のこの神様がもうブラマン系というんですね
後でつけた名前ですけど
バラモン伝統の方が正統派になっちゃって
また無数の宗教があったんですけど
それはまあ正統派じゃないんですね
異端というわけじゃないんだけど
このノントラディショナルというふうに英訳しなくちゃいけないんですね
オーソドックストラディションとノンオーソドックストラディションというふうに学者が言葉を作るんで
異端ではないんです これは西洋で出てきた考えで
異端っていうのはね インド文化では異端はないんです
まあオーソドックスから違いますとそれだけ
それはそちらにそのやり方でやるのは自由ですと
その柔軟性って このおおらかさがね
インド文化でよくありまして
そこでまあヒンドゥー教には宗教
バラモン教には宗教はなかったんですから
はっきり言えばね いくら金儲けて人を育て上げて
それでいいんじゃないかなと
人は死後どうなるか それはわかったことでも考えたこともないんですね
死後のことを考えたのは
このインドの元々あった人々
宗教家たちなんですね
そこでこの異端とか排他はなかったんだから
どうしても支配された側の文化と知識取り入れなくちゃあかんから
そちらから学んでもらわなきゃどうにもならんですね
そういうわけだからね
そちらから学んで自分の文化に取り入れるんですね
だからヴェーダ聖典でなんとなく死後のことも考え出したりする
じわじわとその思考が出てくる
死後といえば まあ天に生まれるか
まあ天に生まれるんだ
天に行くためには まあ何かエネルギーが必要ですから
これで自分の宗教にそれ考え出すんで
バラモン人が供養する
儀を行いばよろしいんだと
だからこの父の世界という名前で天界という言葉ではなかったんですね
で 天界ではという言葉はまあ後からついたもので
父の世界というピートルですね
まあ世界になって 親戚が死んだら
特に息子が供養しなくちゃいけないと
供養はバラモン人が行わなくちゃいけないということで
それで商売は成立という
自分たちが儲かるようにしっかりとそれを作ったんですね
それで困ったことは 息子でなきゃこれ供養できないんですね
もし息子が生まれなかったらどうするのかと
これ大きな問題になっちゃって
だから供養なければ あの父の世界でね
いわゆる戦争ですね 戦争の世界で死んじゃうだろうと
だから天国は永遠ではないんですね
ずっと供養してあげないと
もう向こうは栄養失調で死んじゃいます
大変なことになっちゃった
その概念が入っちゃったんですね
いわゆるセカンドデス
ファーストデスはわかっていることで
それで戦争の世界で生き続けているんだけど
セカンドデスがね 起こるんだ
これ困ったことやってどうしようもないやとね
引っかかるんですね 引っかかったところで
またアーリアの民族と違った人々から学ぶんです
どうしましょうかと 学んだらそちらでは転生するんだという考えがあったんです
じゃあこれもらいましょうと
わかった これもらいますと
セカンドデスが起きても
どこかに戻りますよと
だから丁寧にヴェーダ聖典は読めないんだよ
あれ 古い古代のサンスクリット語だから
そう簡単じゃないんです
読みたければ一流の学者について
もうできればインドのバラモン系の人について読んでもらった方がまあ安全
安全ではないんだけど
まあ早く軽く読めるんです
とか難しいんです で 単語一つ一つ研究しなくて
調べなくして調べなくちゃいけないんだからね
で で 転生するという考えがあって
あ 転生といったらどんなことを書いてわからないんで
ですね まあそこでまあ自然の物事はね
転生するということは目に見えるんだからね
植物に水をあげたら植物は大きくなるでしょ
だから水が転生しちゃったんですね
で 果物にもなるでしょ
だから自分が与えた肥料とか
水が果物に生まれ変わって
これをいただくと 自分が与えたものはまた体から出ていて
また転生する そういうふうなことを思ってしまったんですね
で 変わらない魂があるということも
後からアーリア民族以外の人々から学んだもので
生命もそういうふうに転生するならば
何か変わらないものがあるはずやというふうにね
そういういろいろまあ考えて考えて作るんですね
で それがまあ 一部はね
この連中はどう学んだってアホに決まってるんだと相手にしなかった伝統もあったんです
そこはノンオーソドックス
オーソドックスには入らない
教えてくれと言ったら教えてあげるんだけど
はい 教えてもらって帰ってちょうだいと
バラモン人はそちらに帰ってちょうだいと
で 瞑想なんかはヴェーダ聖典ではものすごく貶していたんですね
あんな野蛮人たちがなんか変なことをやっているんだと
この神にお供えして偉大なる派手なお祭りやるんじゃなくてね
隠れてむむと だからムニという言葉もそういう意味なんですね
軽視 軽蔑的な作業なんですね
黙って顔を黒くして黙ってる連中だと
口は利かない連中やと
これ貶してるんです だからムニを貶されていたんですね
ヴェーダでは で その人々はこのだらしない連中がね
儀式儀礼ばっかりやって金儲けるんだけど
もっと宗教は違いますよと
魂は経験しなくちゃいけないよということで
瞑想文化も現れたんですね
そういうふうにインド文明っていうのは
このだから心配しないでください
誰もそんなに丁寧にしたりしませんだからね
で 学者はまあ嘘を言うのは学者の仕事ですからね
自分の都合でまとめて
なんとかね そうして結論を出してますから
それ肩書き持ってますからね
ランレン大学 オックスフォード大学
ケーン大学出ている博士たちだからね
その通りだと認めなくちゃあかんしね
そこはそんなにもまあ研究されてなさないんですけど
まあだから明確にインド文化がどうなったかということはね
まあよくわからないと
いまだに そこでこのいろんな神々が各地方にいるんですね
そちらにアーリア文明が出ていくと
アーリア民族の宗教にその神々が入ってしまうんですね
だから一人の神に名前がもう百とか五百とかね
いくらでもあるんです
今 ヒンドゥー教で一番偉く信仰しているシヴァ神も
何を隠そう アーリア民族でないモヘンジョダロハラッパの人々の神なんです
まるっきり自分と違った神なんですね
シヴァ神といえばヒンドゥー教でもトップです
で もともとシヴァっていうのはこのずっと修行中なんです
だから瞑想する人々が拝んでいた神なんです
それがいろんなシヴァ神が旅出ると
いろんな地方に恐ろしい神になって
破壊の神になって 火の神にもなったりして
もう性格は何やこれはとわからないぐらい複雑になっていくんですね
だからシヴァ神には名前はもう三四百あたりあるんです
そのその地方の神の名前をつけたりする
だからなんだこりゃなんですよ
それでヒンドゥー教を学んだシヴァ神の本当の姿は何なのかというと
学問も論文を書こうと思っても無理なんです
何かテキストを参考にしてそちらに書いているものを言うだけで
だからあらゆる神話 あらゆる人間の物語
全部シヴァ神につけたりする
シヴァ神の首に蛇を巻いておく
なぜかというと 蛇を信仰した地方もありましたから
で アーリア民族は戦いの民族だから
だからシヴァ神はいつでも何か鬼を潰してるんですね
そういう風に象徴的に形作ることを始めたのは
それ仏教の影響で あの
昔のそんなに大したものは見つからないんですね
で インドを発掘するとほとんど見つかるのは仏教遺跡で
だから仏教に対立しなくちゃいけないんだから
ヒンドゥーの人々もいろいろ神の彫刻を作ったり
もう頑張ってはいたんですけど
芸術的にはそんなに優れていないんです
考え方はちょっとそういうわけもわからない考えですからね
神を作ったら指が何本もあったり
首が何個もあったりね
で 子供を守る神ですけど
カーリーがね 守るか殺すかわからないんですけど
子供をくわえて口に食べているんですね
だからこいつは子供を食べて殺す神か
子供を守る神か ようわからないんです
で いろんな文化を合体するということでね
そこで異端という考えがなかったんだから
それ起こるんですね いまだにインド文化では異端という考えはないんです
変な何か宗教を作ったっても全然大丈夫です
で まあ 2 3  2  3年  5 6年経つとメインの流れに入っているんです
取り入れちゃうんです
追い出すっていうことはないんです
だからこのイスラム教徒は対立を作るのはそういうわけなんです
イスラム教はもう中東から来たもので
断言的に異端主義で 自分の教え以外すべて粉々にするのはもう神の神に対するもう礼やと思っているんですね
だからインド文化に合わないんですね
インド人がどうぞアッラーの神を信仰してくださいと
それでもうシバ神の名前にアッラーとつけただけですからね
もう一つ名前を作るだけです
シバにアッラーとも言いますよと
それで話が平和で無事解決します
これはイスラムの人々は認めないんです
だから仲良くはしてるんだけど
どうかかどこかで もう対立が起きてぶつかっちゃうんですね
で 殺すことになっちゃうと
もうヒンドゥー教は非暴力主義ですから
ものすごい怖いんです
ヒンドゥー教はもともと戦いの宗教なんです
殺す宗教なんです しかし
その殺し方が別にイスラム教的キリスト教的な殺し方じゃなくて
領土を広げる それだけ
だから占領された側と合わせて新しいシステムを作るということ
だから戦争の時は殺されますけど
それから仲良くする だから戦いの宗教なんですね
だから今 この何でしたっけ
宗教の宗教省ではなく
文学作品なんですけど
マハーバーラタっていうのは
そちらのワンチャプターをね
バガヴァッドギーターっていうことで聖書にしているんですね
ヘリックスですけど インド人にはヘリックスじゃないんです
別にいいんじゃない？これ文学作品だろうと言ったって
これを作った人はね 書いた人は知ってますけど
でもこれは神の言葉ですからね
いいんじゃないということで
そんなにややこしいロクスは持ってないんで
このあの 日本でもすごく人気ありますね
バガヴァッドギーターがね
聖なる本を通して あれで殺せ殺せで
初めから終わりまで他何も言ってないんです
よくそれ読めないこと
頭いいんですね ですから
この インド人が非暴力主義やと思ったら
これ勘違いで 当たらない方がいいんです
イスラム人が当たっちゃうと
もうきりがなく潰されます
パキスタンでもカシミール地方でもその問題であって
このカシミールにはイスラム人がいるんだから
これはイスラムのパキスタンの国であるべきやという理屈なんですね
人の宗教からパキスタンになるべきだということはインド人は認めません
それで暴力したり テロ行為やったりしたんですけど
インド人がそれにはめげるわけじゃないんです
私たちはガンディーの教えで非暴力主義だから
それはないんです インドの歴史ではガンディーがおかしい人なんですけど
彼の行動で良い結果出したんだから
否定するわけにはいきません
しかし ガンディーのやり方は良くないと当時の人々は思っていたんです
戦うべきだと で 非暴力主義はどこから来たかと
それはヒンドゥー教に関係ない
ジャイナ教とかね この昔のアーリア系ではない人々の一つの宗教なんですね
だからこの非暴力主義とヒンドゥー教っていうのはどうも噛み合わないんですよ
でも一緒にいること不思議でしょ
殺しの生贄の宗教が もう菜食主義者がいっぱいいるという
誰も違和感を感じないんです
で 神に牛十頭 四十頭 百頭殺してお供えしていたんですよ
それから牛が聖なる牛になっちゃったんですね
だから文献見れば違うだろうと言うんだけど
誰もそれがおかしいと思わないんです
なぜかというと どこか知らないんだけど
シヴァの乗り物が牛になっちゃったんです
それ全然珍しくないんで
モヘンジョダロ文明では牛のシールがものすごくはっきりしてるんです
だから当時が平和な文明でしたから
牛っていうのはありがたい存在なんです
だから尊敬されていたんです
で インド人から見ても
牛って結構ありがたいんですね
養ってくれるんで だからインド文化でパーリ経典でも財産を意味する同義語は牛なんですね
あいつは牛持ちやと言ったら
あいつは金持ちやって意味なんです
あの人は立派な人格者というためには
インド言語ではあの人は牛ですと言えばいいんです
じゃあお釈迦様の名前何でしたっけ？ゴータマでしょ
だから牛の中で一番尊いって意味なんです
だからゴータマっていうのは尊い牛なんです
で 日本語に言えばなんかおかしく感じますけど
私たちは同じ文明だから文化だから全然おかしく感じないんです
今の人を褒めたくなったら牛とつけるんです
その代わりに牛に同義語はたくさんあります
ただの牛だろうやって畜生やっていう風に軽視して見たころ見たければ別な言葉があります
尊い存在やと言いたい場合は別な単語があります
そういう風にもすごい単語があるんですね
だから仏教でもね 人に牛とか呼ぶなよと
それは侮辱になるもなるんだと
ということで 褒める時も使うのに
侮辱するためにも使っていたみたいですね
それでこの神たちがね
もう巨大インドの土地で歩くんだからね
これで牛もすいちゃったんですね
神が偉いというたい場合は
やっぱり牛はつけなくちゃいけないんです
いけない それで神だから牛に乗せてあげたんですね
尊いものの乗せてあげたんです
だから牛を管理するんです
神様が いわゆる幸福 幸せを管理するんですね
そこで具体的にイメージすると
シヴァ神が牛に乗ってるんですね
どんどん時間経つと 牛を殺して神にお供えしたら
神がどんな気持ちになるのかと考えたでしょうね
自分が飼ってる牛を殺しちゃうとえらい悲しくなるでしょ
じゃあこれやめましょうよと言ってきて
いつかわからないんだけど
どんどん牛がまあ尊い動物になっちゃって
もう誰も殺さない インドはもう人間と同じぐらい牛がうろうろうろうろいろんなところにいる
というふうに まあいろんなことがね
まあそれ一つも矛盾だ
変だとは思わないんですね
だから異端思考はないんです
仏教はもう断言的に もう革命的にまるっきり違うことを教えたんです
だからインド文化から見れば
もうとんでもない革命者なんです
何一つもインド人の神秘的な価値観を認めません
じりじり知識人で もうインド人にわからないんだけど
ものすごい精密な科学者で
だったら 1 日で潰されるでしょ
できないで 異端という概念がないんだから
その人は別な角度で何か大事なことを教えているだろうと言って学んで仏教徒になってしまうんですね
それで仏教の力が弱くなったところで
まあ大乗仏教のおかげですけど
まあ仏教の力が弱くなっちゃって
もうなんていうのは独立して立つことできなくなってきたんですね
それでヒンドゥー教はね
異端ではないんだから
牛を捨てるわけにはいきませんだからそれはヒンドゥー教の一部だと
ある時は神様が人間を救うためにそういうふうに教えもしましたよと
その時はその教えが必要でしたと
終わりとお話はと だから昔はブッダがすごいインドで活動して
それはその時期でよかったと
だから神様ですと 今は我々はまた元のだらしない恐ろしいことをやってますよと
今ブッダはいらんやということになって
仏教は捨ててないんですね
仏教はインドにないんだけど
文化的にはまあ異端ではないんだから
まあ中に取り入れて それで話が終わってしまうんです
だからヒンドゥー教に吸収されると
その思想がもう死んでしまうんです
終わってしまうんですね
だからモヘンジョダロ・アラプの古代文明の一欠片もないんですが
まだまだ本当は隠れて生きているんです
ミトコンドリアみたいな感じで隠れては生きているんです
これ取り出して 学問的に取り出して
これやっていう学者がいないんですね
これからもないでしょう
まあまあ それよりはパソコンのエンコーディング
まあ何とか金儲かりますからね
だからインド人はそれをやっているんです
まあ数学は基本的には上手でしょうし
理論性は持ってるしね
理屈は上手でしょ もってこいの仕事なんです
プログラム組むことが
これでアメリカの会社がインド人に頼んでプログラム作ってもらって自分の名前で売ってるだけ
マイクロソフト会社で言ったらもう半分ぐらいインド人だと思いますけど
時々日本にも会社もね
まあ雇ってもらったりする
まあだからこういうことは研究しないだろうと思います
それでまあインドラという神に話を戻して早く終了しましょう
この話はもうちょっと長くて
ね で 戦いの神ですけど
性格ははっきりしないのはインド文化なんです
いろんなところで旅すると
そちらのそちらの文化によって変わってしまうでしょうし
いわゆる足して足していくんですね
足す時はまるっきり正反対のもの足しちゃいますけど
異端がないんだから一つ取り出す捨てるということはないんですね
ですから このヒンドゥー教では
インドラが戦いの神でありながら神でもある
全ての人々を守ってくれる神でもある
幸福の神でもある 家族を守る神でもある
それから修行者を導く
ウパニシャッドやってる
ヨーガやってる人々を導く神でもあると
だから瞑想しながら人を殺すというね
オウム真理教みたいな感じでね
そちらもシヴァの仏像を作っちゃったんだから
最後にアサダが先生も宗教に興味のなかった人みたいし
だからこの品物をですね
人を騙すためにどんな品物をよろしいかって
それは選ぶんで だから用語単語だけですね
借りるのはワジラヤーナとかね
ワジラは何か分からないんです
マントラヤーナとか 普通の本読んだらありますからね
そういう用語を言ったりして
それで日本人がまんまと騙すんですね
単語を言ったら騙されるという弱みがあったんだからね
意味の意味は調べません
その欠点をうまく使って
もうシヴァ神のね まああれもそうか
もう彫刻も作って そこで一言しましょうと
みんなはい わかりましたと
で ヒンドゥー教では殺しは別に悪いことじゃないんですね
殺しは正しい行為になっていたんですね
そこで絶対殺さなかれという教えとは仲良くすることできんでしょうに
バラモン教以外の文明の
だから仏教もバラモンオーソドックスとは違ったものなんですね
きれいに違ったものなんです
お釈迦様も結局オーソドックスの家の人なんですね
それをしっかり学んでいて
オーソドックスと違ったところに入ってしまったんだから
お釈迦様はやっぱり信頼されるんです
それおかしいことをやったと思わないんです
これは昔からもやっていたものだからね
アーリア民族が支配された人々から学ぶということで
昔からもやっていたものだから
お釈迦様がやったことは全然おかしくもなんともないんです
インド人にとっては それでよくわかったといえば
じゃあ行って学びましょうよと
それでバラモン人がさーっと行って
ブッダの教えを聞くんです
だから異端という概念がないということは
すごくいいところがありまして
結局はゴミばっかり溜まるという現象があります
わけもわからなくなっちゃって
ゴミ処分しないんですね
だから仏教の特色はそこでなんか本当に理解できると思いますね
仏教はゴミを処分するんです
全部 しかし 異端という概念は仏教でもないんです
だから欠点を隠し直したんです
異端の概念はないんだけど
ゴミは処分する いたんだからではなくて
これはもういらん 邪魔ということでね
処分するんですね だからこの処分するところはなかなかインド人には理解できないんですね
このインド哲学 ヒンドゥーのインドの哲学というウパニシャッドっていうのは
ブラフマン系のオーソドックス教えとは違いますよ
それは後でできたものなんですね
お釈迦様より少々古いんですけど
お釈迦様の時代からお釈迦様後で 100年
200年あたりでウパニシャッドっていうのはほとんどできて終わっちゃったんです
お釈迦様はそんなにウパニシャッドテキストがあったことっていうのはそれほど知らなかったんです
ということはできてなかったんですね
できてたならば お釈迦様も知っているでしょうし
で この古いテキストを一つ二つ以外
ウパニシャッドでもブッダに引用されたこともないんですね
だから同時に現れた 現れ始めただろうというふうに思うんですね
はい そういうことで この仏典にも神々が登場します
それで神々の名前になってくると困るんですね
たまたまこの当時でみんな信仰している名前を使う
このブラフマっていうのはそういうことで
梵天ですね で これがあのブラフマン教だからブラフマではなく
これも後から他の人々の信仰なんですよ
神が清らかで尊くて 汚れがなく
欲がなく 存在を作って
生命とすべて森羅万象を作って
穏やかに自分が作った作品だから
何の迷惑もかけないでじーっといる
だから 創造論としては世界で一番かっこいい創造論なんです
インドにある創造論は
ブラフマが作った場合はね
梵天が一切作っちゃって
だからあるものは全部梵天が作ったものだから
潰すんじゃないんです
うまくバランスを整えているでしょ
世界を見ると アリが邪魔やってことはありえないはずなんです
アリも必要です 死ぬアリも必要です
昆虫も必要です だから誰か敵に回しちゃって殺すっていうことはね
創造論を信じるならば変です
ありえないんですけど
だからこの中東の創造論っていうのは
もう世にあってはならない間違いだらけの創造論なんです
だから ジェホワとかね
名前を出した時点であいつは神でないということをはっきりしているんです
ブラフマは梵天じゃそうじゃないんですね
やっぱり全部まあ 見守っている
邪魔しない で そこで流れてうまくいく
で そこの中で一部の人々は精神的に優れて
精神を開発しなくちゃいけないんだということで瞑想したりして
ブラフマを経験しようと
ブラフマの世界に行こうと
そこは人間の生きている生命
みんなの人間だけじゃなくてね
最終的な目的であるべきでしょうと
家に戻ること で そういうふうにブラフマ神が入ってきて
それはヒンドゥ教にも入っちゃって
でもさっさと無視されるんですね
一旦入れてから じゃあそれから無視されるんです
ブッダの時代では バラモン人がブラフマとの世界に行くことがものすごく喜んで期待していたんです
現代ヒンドゥ人はそう思ってないんです
全くも おそらく名前も知らないかも
だから宗教が時代によって目的まで変わるんだから
お前ら変だよと言ったっても
それはわからないんだ
人が何が変ですか？と
正反対のことを言っているではないかと言って
別にそれでいいんじゃない？という
異端意識はないんです
外国に行ったらね ヒンドゥ教の人々は何の躊躇もなく教会でお祈りするんです
あんたヒンドゥー教でおかしいでしょうに
全然思ってないんです
で キリスト教の教会もなくて
仏教のお寺があったらお寺に行くんです
真面目にお祈りして帰るんです
違和感とか全然感じません
だからそれはあの人々の遺伝子の中に異端という概念が入ってないんだから
なんです そこでブラフマという言葉があって
ブッダの時代ではブラフマ神様には立場があったんです
だから仏教では このその類の生命を説明する場合
いわゆる心清らかで落ち着いていて
いわゆるすごい格が高い
欲に染まってない神々を示す場合は
ブラフマという言葉を使っているんですね
そこでブラフマの神々って仏教は個人のことを語ってますから
やっぱりブラフマは個人個人になっちゃって
ブラフマ 神々になっちゃって
そうすると名前が必要になっちゃうんですね
個人には 名前をつける場合は
まあもうもともとインドにあった名前のプラジャーパティという名前を一応使ったように
プラジャーパティといえば
全ての生命を創った神っていう意味なんです
仏教ではプラジャーパティさんなんです
人の名前なんですね 特に仏教に関わる神の名前はサハンパティというんですね
またいろんな名前の神
梵天 神々も出てくる で
その世界で帝釈天というサッカ
インドラ マグといういくつかの名前で知られている神も登場したんですね
で 仏教は本当に気をつけて
人の考えは取り入れないということには気をつけるんですけど
やっぱり名前とかいろいろ入ったりはする
入って中身を見ると 仏教は仏教独特の世間観で全て見ているんだから
結局は一つもヒンドゥー教のパクリがなくなっているんですね
言葉は使います だから涅槃という言葉を使いますけど
あったんです 中身は違います
で インドにある言葉は全部
言葉使わなくちゃいけないんだからね
使いますけど 仏教はまあアイデアはパクりません
で 全く仏教の仏教なりの説明があるんです
だから神神々の世界っていうのは
多次元の世界にせよ 多数の生命が住んでいる世界になっちゃって
まあ生命の次元論を語ったりしてね
だから輪廻転生はありますとね
それはパクった考えではなくてね
輪廻転生の考えはすごい発達したのは仏教なんです
これ仏教の考えなんですね
なんとなく展開する 転生するだろうというだけ思考しかなかったんですね
体が変化しない 魂が移転するという
それはありえないと仏教は言うんですね
変化しないものは移転しない
変化するんだから変わるんだよと
ということで 無常の真理に達した輪廻転生なんですね
無常は発見したんだから
まあそれだったら当たり前で輪廻は成り立つんだよということなんですね
それはいまだのいまだに知識人に理解できない
難しいんですから もうちょっと進化すれば理解できると思います
これは進化 ブッダがちょっと早すぎなんです
であと500年ぐらい経ったところで
500じゃなくて5000年ぐらい経ったところに現れたら
当たり前やと思うかもしれませんだけど
そこまで人類がいるかもわからないし
条件そろったの同時なんです
ブッダに現れる だからまあ同時で
今はね まあみんなね 無常だから輪廻ないだろうとへっちゃらで言うんですね
あんた原始人かいと私は聞きたくなっちゃいますけどね
無常だから転生するでしょうにと
そういうことで いろいろまあ
当時インドに一般的に知られていた名前の神々も仏教に出てきて
インドでなかった神々
お釈迦様は特別知っている神々の名前は大量にあるんです
しかし インド人の文化にその神々が流行らなかったんですね
こういう神がいるんだ
こういう神がいるんだとお釈迦様はおっしゃってますけど
こういう神が来て 私にこういうことを言いましたと
私も一緒にこんなことを言い返したとかね
で 対話はあるんだけど
その神々のアんまり一般人の間では知られていないんです
面白いことは スリランカ人もこの仏教
仏典に出てくる神々に対して全然気にもしないんですよ
おかしいんですよ まあ例えば
あの祇園精舎作って寄付したアナータピンディカが
あの ちょっと名前思い出せないんですよ
なんとかというと 名前でもう天国に神になっているんですよ
で 今もいるんです だから仏教徒たちの随分面倒見てくれた
心配してくれた仲間でしょうに
ちょっともう何々さん
まあ今なんとか助けてくれと言ったっても悪くはないんだけど
まるっきり無視 無関心
その代わりに存在すらもしないヒンドゥの神々を拝んでるんです
ヴィシュヌ神とか ガネーシュとか
仏典に入ってないんです
いわゆるそれは存在すらもしないんだからね
名前ぐらい使ってもいいんで使いきないんです
どうなっているのかってよくわからない
まああのタイ人だけはブラフマ神も信仰しますけど
それも直々のヒンドゥ教の影響なんです
スリランカ人はブラフマンはもう仏典から知っているだけで
全然仏像も仏像ではなくて
このブラフマの像も作りませんし
全くもないんです 消えちゃったんですね
文化から やっぱりヒンドゥー文化文化がすごい生き続くんですね
ヒンドゥ文化はもう結構強い
もう潰せないんですね
潰せない理由は異端という概念がないだからなんです
だから敵じゃないんだから
あなた私が違う教えを持っています
あ そう 別にいい 構いませんよと言うんだから
それ時点でもう対立さがなくなっちゃうんです
別にそれで構いませんよ
そういうことで この 神々の王っていう話に入ります
で これがこの普通の神々です
神々といえば この仏教から見れば
人間とほぼ同じくね 欲もあるし
遊んで生活している 感情がある生命体なんですね
それではなく 優れているといえば
ブラフマ梵天と言うんですね
だから世間とは結構関わりは持っている
その中でこの四天王という概念があって
まあ一番人間界に近い天界なんですね
で 王様が４人がいるんですね
で それもまあ名前を見れば
インドの文化的に何か見つかりますけど
で 仏教では派手に登場するんですね
その上 ヤーマという天界があって
もっと上 兜率天 ターワティ３３天というのがあるんですね
で 結構レベルが高いんで
その帝釈天がそちらにいるんです
もっと上が天界 ヤーマ
兜率天というんですね
優れている神々がいるんですね
それから竹地再天と  何でしたっけ
ニンマーナラティとパラニミタワサワティという
また２回がありまして ６
の段階に神々は作っているんです
作っているかどうか まあそういうふうにありますよと
で この神の話なんですね
はい それでこの仏教は
この こんなすごい神がいるんだよという話ではなくてね
まあ仏教を教えるんですよ
この名前借りて 普通の考えは死後天国に生まれることです
一般人の常識的な希望に反対はしないが
大胆で現実的なことを教えるのはお釈迦様のやり方なんです
だから 地球上のどんな人間も
死んでから天国に行きたいと思っているんです
死んでから私は地獄に行きたくてたまらないという人は存在しないんです
それは宗教歩かなきゃ関係ないんですよ
死んだら天国に行きたいなというふうな
この思考が基本的に誰にもあります
仏教はそれにおかしいやとは言わないんです
が 大胆なことを言うんです
従って 死後天に生まれるのではなく
天王になる方法を説かれるのです
では 君たちの死後天国に生まれる方法を教えますではなくて
まあ勝手に行ったっても
行くんだったら王ぐらいになってくださいというね
そこでちょっと失礼なことを言うんですね
天界に生まれるんじゃなくて
天界で天王になる 天王になる道を教えますよと
だから なんか侮辱的な言葉でしょ
あえてそう言うんです
だから 人間の一般的な無知な人々の思考には乗らないんです
乗らないんだけど 逆らったらもうみんなおかしいんだ
頭おかしいんだからね
混乱するんだから 逆らってないような顔をするんです
賛成しているんだって
これ インド文化的なやり方なんです
異端はないんです 異端という概念ないんだけど
潰して消せるんです 仏教独特のやり方で
だから神の王になる道を教えるんです
で サッカインドとは 古代インド人が信仰した神々の王であり
敵を倒して勝利を与える神でもあったのです
そのキャラを使用しているんです
はい いきなり始まります
神の王になる道 ７つあります
ヤーワジーワンマータペッティバロウアッサン
生涯両親を養う そこで神の王になった人が人間でいた時はそういう誓いをしたんだと
私は生涯両親を養いますと
二番目 ヤーワジーワンクレージェッターペチャイアッサン
ここでこの男は決めるんです
私は生涯家にいる目上の人を敬う
家にいるって言ったら家ですね
まあくれくらっていうのは自分の家系ですね
家系の目上の人々を敬うとか
敬うということはどんな意味ですかね
敬うというよりも 従う
面倒を見る 義務を果たすというようなニュアンスなんですね
このクレージェッターペチャイのっていうのは
おじいさん おばあさんたちの話を聞いたり
尊敬したり まあ伝統を守ったり
その家系のしきたりを守ったり
そういうことをね 全部やりますと
家系を潰すことはしません
で 三番目 ヤージーワンサンハワーチョアッサン
生涯優しい言葉使う人間になる
とてもとても言葉を戒めて優しい言葉を喋りますと
いわゆる敬語で丁寧な言葉で
人の心が傷つく言葉は全然使わないという
まあ慣れちゃえば至って簡単なことなんです
私に無理みたいですけどね
なるつもりがないんですね
はい 続きですね ヤーワジーワンアピスノワーチョアッサン
生涯噂話をしない この噂話にも解説があります
噂とは他人の悪口を言うことなんですよ
あの 褒めることではないんです
噂はしないと言ったら
これちょっと実行できないんですよ
我々は噂のようなことを知って
それを知識にもしていますね
あの人はこうでした こういうことをしました
ああいうことをしましたと喋るでしょう
例えば知名度のある人々
有名人 あ こういう人はこういうことを言ったとかね
それは人がないところで
その人について語ることでしょうね
それは噂ですか？と 噂じゃないんです
噂っていうのは悪口を言うことなんです
人を非難 侮辱することですね
本人がいないところで
たとえ悪い人間であっても
こちらでないんだったら
もう何も言わないことにする
その人に対しては それ
そんなことですね 別に人のことを喋っても構わないよ
それはその人の大事なところ
勉強になるところ 役に立つところも
いないところでいくら喋ったってもよろしいんです
五番目 ヤーワジーワンウィガタマラマッシェーレーナチェーテサーラーアガーランアッジャワセユン
これは場所がないんだから省略して訳していますけど
まず直訳します ヤーワジーワンというのは生涯ヴィガタマラマチェラっていうのは
このケチのという汚れから心を清らかにして
物惜しみ ケチで心は汚れるんです
このケチな心では 物惜しみに汚れた心では生活しません
心でアガーラン 在家生活は
しますと いわゆるケチ
物惜しみに汚れない心で私は生活しますと
次の単語は で この矢印は言ってるで
もっとチャーブ チャーガっていうのは寄付をあげることに
もっと自分が解放しているんです
でもあげますと 次の単語はパヤートパーニン
パヤートパーニンっていうのは
これ文学表現で はい どうぞっていうふうに手を伸ばしてるんです
えっと 矢印を見なくなっちゃった
パヤートパニ ゴッサーガラと
ゴッサーガっていうのは
自分持っているものはもう離す
離す 離すことなんですね
自分から これ好きなんですね
自分持っているものはあげたくてあげたくて
はい 持ってってください
持ってってくださいと
いう精神で生活しますと
次 ヤーチャヨーゴ ヤーチャヨーゴ
ヤーチャっていうのはお願いする場合にふさわしいお願い
誰か何か困った時は 私のところに何の躊躇もなく来られるように生活しますと
性格を変わり 変わります
変えますと だから自分がまあ頼みやすいタイプなんですね
ものを頼みやすいタイプ
その性格になりますと
それでダーナサンヴィバーガだと
最後の言葉はダーナサンヴィバーガ
ダーナっていうのは寄付すること
サンヴィバーガっていうのは分かち合うこと
持っているものは人にあげたり
分かって分け合って生活する性格の人間になりますと
これもヤーワジーワン
生涯やりますと で 省略して訳してやりますからね
まあ寄付を好む 与える習慣で
頼みやすい人間で 分かち合う性格を持って生きると
6番目 ヤーワジーワンサッチャワーチョアッサン
生涯真理を語る人になる
嘘をつかないということなんですね
喋ったら本当の真実しか喋れませんよと
嘘は絶対言わないというすごい厳しいマッチも守っているんですね
これもヤーワジーワン 7
番目 ヤーワジーワンアッコーダノワッサン
サティピメーコードウパッジャイヤ
キッパメーワナンパティウィネーヤン
意味は生涯怒らない人間になる
もし怒ったことがあっても
たちまち怒りを収めると
これで七つです で 五戒と違うでしょ
これはもう計算上で言ってるんです
なんか五戒のね 嘘をつかないとかも入ってますけどね
それって違います で 何が違うかというと
五戒といえば これは仏教独特の戒律ですからね
他宗教ではもう守ったり守らなかったりとかね
いろいろ回数もはっきり定めて決まってないし
仏教では五戒と 在家には五戒とははっきり回数も定めているんですね
それ言っちゃうと仏教の教えになっちゃうんですね
帝釈天を超えるインドラ神を信仰するのは仏教だけじゃないんだから
インド人ならみんな信仰しているんだから
だからお釈迦様がそこはよく知って
みんなに反対できない
納得いく そういえば俺にもできないわけじゃないんだよと
いう人間の希望をかなり上げちゃうんです
この惨めな死んじゃったら天国には行きたいやというね
これ そなた王製の希望ではね
ないんです 皆さんも気をつけて
皆さんもだいたいそなた王政の思考で生きているでしょ？まあ
学校を卒業してからどこかで就職して
それで終わりと 人生はと
こんなつまらないでしょう
なんか大胆な希望があった方がいいでしょう
大衆と違ったことをやるぞと
なかなかそういう人間少ないんですよ
だから大胆でもういまだかつてない何かをやるとかね
それが生き延びるためには欠かせない条件なんですよ
今の現代社会を見ても
このままだったら潰れますよ
間もないうちに 大胆でいまだかつてない何か
何か 何かやらないと生き延びないんです
大衆もその他大勢の考えに従って生きていたら
もうもうただ消えるだけ
そんな人もいたんですかと
それではダメなんですよ
だからまあ お釈迦様がみんなの希望は死んだら天国に行けばいいでしょうとかね
それで随分希望が小さくて落ち着いているんですけども
気に入らん お釈迦様にとっては
王になれと 死後天国ではなくて
死後天の王になると という教えなんですね
だからそんなこと言ったって
もうどうなれるかという
あんた知ってるのかと
今 天皇天皇王になってるやつがね
この七つ回ったんだよと
これ回ればいいでしょうにと
だから面白いことは 天界があってもなくても
天に王がいてもいなくても
仏説は真理なんです これが人類をやってみたらどうなるんですかね
この社会は どんな人でも生涯親を養って面倒を見ること悪いことですかね
皆様 中国の強さは何かと知ってますかね
懸命に頑張るから 北京やら上海やら
そういう大都会に出て行って
出稼ぎに行ってこそこそ仕事するんだからとか
そんなことじゃないと思いますよ
遠い田舎からでも人が都会に行っても
家族との関係がものすごいんです
親に対する愛着はすごいんです
だからそれで行くんですよ
だから苦労なんかは全然気にもしない
頑張る 頑張っていくらか金が入ったらさっさとお母さんに家族に送ってあげる
おばあさん おじいさんのことはまあ好きで好きでしょうがないんですね
でお母さんよりもおばあさん
おじいさんのこと 孫たちがまあ可愛がってあげて
尊敬して あの家族のあの絆
あれはもうかなわないんですよ
あれ すごい頑張る力を与えてくれるんです
だから中国人は強いんです
強さは親を大事にするところから出てくるんです
何でもする 何でもって言ったら悪いことはしませんだけど
普通は今子供一人しかいないでしょう
で 金持ちの連中が一人の子供におじいさんおばあさんが金あげて面倒見るわ
両親がやりたい放題ことやっちゃうた
やるわ やるわ 世界最低の人間になるはずでしょ
そこまでもう贅沢に育てると
勉強させたければ 授業料は 10万でも 20万でももう塾に払うわ
ちょっと大きくなって車が欲しいなと思ったら高級車買ってあげるわ
それだったら世界最低最悪の人間に大きくなるはずでしょ
ならないんです これって不思議でしょうかね
単純です 親を大事にする
親孝行する 中国の言葉
親孝行ですからね これが遺伝子に入っちゃってね
いくら他の文化学んでも
いくら英語を学んでも
いくらアメリカ大学で博士までやっちゃっても
中国人には変わりはありません
だからね それがなくならないんです
だから叶わないんですよ
世界は ブッダがあの連中
そんな話を前に教えてあるんです
これが王道であると ですから
別に私にクレームつけたっても
仏教では本当に帝釈天いるんですかね
それは迷信じゃないんです
どうでもいいんです そんなのは
お釈迦様はその概念を
キャラをね 使って革命的なことを教えてるんです
それからもうすごい精密にね
例えば怒ることについては
私は生涯怒らないことにしますと
とは言っても 時々怒っちゃうということがね
あるんですよ だからそこも入れて
あったらすぐその場で消すんだよと
死後天国だと謳いすす人は生活しています
釈尊は人間の理想的な生き方を天に生まれる方法として説かれています
だから人間の理想を説かれてるんですよ
理想を追うより先に理性的な人間になりなさいっていう戒めですよ
理想を追うんじゃなくて
理性的な人間になりなさいと
しかし それは当時の人間には読めないんです
お釈迦様のこの革命的にもう全部破壊して新しいことを教えているんだっていうことは
これはなく あ なるほど
あんたおっしゃっていることその通りだと感じるだけで
自分の考えは片っ端から根底から潰したってことは気づいてないんです
だから私の厳しい言葉に入れ替えると
理想を追うんじゃないんだよと
理性になりなさいとなんです
理想をやめて理性になる
お釈迦様それをおっしゃってるんです
だから 七つの項目は理性的に生きることなんです
だから天国があってもなくてもどうでもいいんです
死後天国という願望をが迷信と信仰から切り離すんです
だからお釈迦様が死後天国に行きたいと願う
あれは迷信でしょ 別に知らないし
全く知らない 死後はどうなるのかと
天国に行くだろうと信じているだけで迷信なんです
この迷信は潰したらよくないでしょう
死後はないんだと言ったら
ものすごい反発受けますよ
死後は天国に行けるわけないだろと言ったら
すごい反発を受けるんです
だからその死後は天界に生まれ変わりたいって
これが迷信なんですけど
お釈迦様が迷信は迷信でないことにしちゃったんです
現実的な話にしちゃったんです
現実的な話は親孝行する
自分のものは分かち合って生活する
目上の人の話を聞く だから育ってるのは育つのは目上の人でしょ
誰でも アメリカでも あんな大胆に乱暴な生き方ではうまくいかないでしょうに
いつでも目上の人は次の世代を育てているでしょうに
だからよく育ってもらわなきゃダメでしょうに
だから目上の人に可愛いと
この愛情が生まれなきゃもうダメでしょう
もう生きていられないんです
だから目上の人々は まあこいつら本当に可愛いね
心配ねとかね 面倒を見てあげなくちゃというふうな気持ちがね
生まれてもらったら もうすごい幸せで生きていられます
育ててくれます 教えてくれます
導いてくれます 間違い直してくれます
正しいやり方を教えてくれます
これは腹が立っても意味がないんですよ
例えば父親には敵わないんだ
それはそれでいいんです
父親が全部丁寧に教えてあげますからね
敵わないと思ったっても
知らんうちに一人前になってるはずなんです
そういうことで お釈迦様がこの迷信は迷信でなくなった状態にしたんです
はい それからこれ大事な七種のポイントですから
暗記してほしいんです
暗記してほしいものはすべて芸にするんです
歌にするんです で スリランカ人も
これはたまたまお坊さんたちもたまたま覚えてますけどね
スリランカ人がヒンドゥー教だからね
まあ覚える必要ないんですけど
マーターペッティバランジャントゥンクレージェッダハチャイナン
サンナンサキラサンバサン
ペーすねいやっぱハイナン
これ美しく歌うんですよ
マーターペッティバランジャントゥンクレージェッダハパチャイナン
サンナンサキラサンバサン
ペーすねいやっぱハイナンというふうな
で 覚えたら項目が全部入っています
マーターペッティバランジャントゥンというのは
人は両親を養うものやと
クレージェッダハプチャイナンというのは
家系の目上の人々を尊敬するものやと
で 次はちょっと長く伸ばしてるんで
それを美しく言うためなんですね
優しい言葉を語り 噂話を避ける
このサンナンサキラサンバサンというのは優しい言葉なんです
だけど 優しい言葉って短いでしょ
パーリ語ではサンナンサキラサンバサンというすごい美しい文学的な表現なんです
サンナンというのはすごい優しいというね
もう気持ちいいということで
サキラサンバサンというのは
仲のいい友達の会話っていう
ものすごい仲のいい友達がガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ喋ってるでしょ
そんな気持ちで喋るという言葉遣いなんです
で ４行目はペーすねいや
ペーすねいや パハイナン
噂を避ける  ね マッシェーラ
ヴィナレーユッタン サッチャンコダビブンナラン
タンウェーデーヴァーターヴァティンサー
アーフサンプリソーイティー
物惜しみなく真理を語り
怒りを収める 三十三点
三十三点はこのようでありと
仙人は説く で なんで帝釈天
釈迦 インドラとか使わないで三十三点と出て持ったかというと
あなた方のインドラ神をパクったんじゃないんだよと
仏教の天界の説明で  3番目の天界は三十三点なんです
そちらの王の名前はマゲですよと
で マゲはその人は再起で人間にいた時の名前なんです
はい これでまとめたんですね
七章はね まあこれで話終わりですけど
はい 怒りを切り殺せっていうね
釈尊が神々の王に説法する
で あの神々の王はこの怒りを収めることにはすっごい人気でしたね
怒らないんだと これはもう彼の看板でした
怒らないんですよ 王のくせに
いつでもニコニコニコニコと
他のところでちょっとだらしないところは見えますけど
性格的に それはもうだらしないところもなんとなく可愛い性格なんですけど
怒らないんですね 管理者ですけど
これで結構人気があって
みんなに尊敬されちゃったんですね
で ある日 帝釈天との問答を切るんです
お釈迦様もすごい仲良しでね
お釈迦様のお世話係もやっていたしね
お釈迦様はこの最後というか
もっと前からね 病気で倒れた時はね
お釈迦様も一応体力はありましたけどね
赤痢になってね で 胃がずっと良かったんだ
お釈迦様 お釈迦様がね
まあ赤痢になったんだから
惨めな姿でしょう もうみんなの前に顔を出したくはなかったんです
だから誰もそばに来るなよと隠れちゃったんです
病気治るまで誰もお世話しなかったんです
お釈迦様は大体の比丘たちを追い出しちゃったんだからね
誰も近寄れない 行かないんですね
行ったらそういう帝釈天がね
すぐそこをわかって さっさとそんなこと言ったってもね
誰か面倒見なきゃ困るでしょということで
もう降りてきて お釈迦様がお世話したんです
お釈迦様を追い出そうとするんですね
お前も出ていけと どういったけど
あのね お前らにはね 人間そのもの臭くて耐えられないでしょ
この肉体は ものすごい臭いみたいです
そばに寄れないんです
あまりにも悪臭で これは人間の体そういうことでしょ？今
私の姿どうですか？とお釈迦様さえも人間に顔を出したくないんですね
この赤痢下痢でしたから
出ていけと ただ帝釈天が私はね
この人間の肉体をめがけて来たわけじゃないんだよと
お釈迦様のこの清らかな尊い心の香りは梵天まで届くんだよと
だからそばにいさせてくれることは
私にとってはどれほどありがたいかと
わかってちょうだいと
そしたら黙ったんですね
で 帝釈天がもうお世話したんですよ
便所の掃除やら全部やったんです
人間に人間の体に帰ってね
だからお釈迦様のお便所のツボも
なんか尊いものを持ってくるの
頭に乗せて持っていくんだと
片す時も ね もう便をね
ポットに入れちゃうでしょうに
そこはそのまま取って
頭の上に載せて外へ持っていくと
そこまでお釈迦様にもまあ仲良し面倒見た人なんです
が 時々まだらしないこともあると
問題はこういう問題なんで
天皇の質問はキンスチェットはすかんせーてきんすチェットはね
そうチェティキッサスエトダンマッサワダンローチェイシゴータマ
ゴータマとお釈迦様前ですね
立派な牛という 何を切り殺して幸福になりますか？何を切り殺して悩まないでしょうか
破壊を期待するべき唯一のものは何でしょうか
と えらいなぞなぞの質問ですね
一つありますよ これは何ですか？と
これは切り殺さなくちゃ
切り殺したら幸せになると
ブッダの言葉 コーダンチェットワスカンセーティ
コココーダンチェットワナソーチェティコーダッスヴィサムーラッセンマドゥラッガッスワーサワ
ワダンアリアパサンサンティタンタンヒチェットワナソーチェティ
こちらでこの上から 4行目の最後の単語
ワーサってありますね
下から上から 4行目 下から 3行目ですね
もう最後 ワーサっていうのは帝釈天のもう一つの名前なんです
ワーサヨ 怒りを切り殺して幸福になる
怒りを切り殺す 殺すと悩まない
根源は毒で 先は甘く見える怒りの破壊を聖者が讃嘆する
怒りを切り捨てるとする
切り捨てる人に悩みはありません
と だから悩まなくて 幸せに生きるためには
やるべき唯一なことは怒りを切り殺すことです
すごい便利な教えでしょうに
覚えやすいでしょうに
幸福で楽しく 悩みは悩みて何の縁もなく生きてきたければ
怒りは切り殺すのです
たとえ親戚 親しい人が亡くなったら悩むでしょ？なくなるんです
怒りを切り殺している人にとっては全然悩みの種にならないんです
ニコッてに対応する それから怒りのお釈迦様は明確にね
このヴィパッサナーラッセン
怒りが毒から発生するんですね
怒りそのものが毒なんですね
毒から発生して花が咲くようなもんなんですけど
この花触ってはあかん
だから怒っている人は喜んで怒っているんですよ
怒って何が悪いんですかと
正しいと思っているんですね
怒って人を怒鳴ったりするときは
えらい気分がいいでしょ
人を脅して抑えて胸を張って帰ること
毒を食べているんで あいつは
だから表面的にそう見えても
怒鳴った方がいい 怒った方がいい
コラーと言った方がいいと
そうじゃないんだ あれ毒なんです
だからそこをちゃんと釈迦様が
根元は毒 これ毒が咲かした花です
取るんじゃないんです
まあキノコの場合もね
一番美しく美味しく見えるのは毒キノコでしょ
はい それで今日のテーマの話は全部終わりましたので
まあちょっと雑談的なちょこっとことを言います
帝釈天も天国でね 神々の管理しなくちゃいけないんだからね
いろいろ発表したり こうしなさいと言ったりはするときはあります
帝釈天がよく喋った話の一つなんですね
マーボーこうどアジバビ
マーチャくじったくじたんアッコードアヴィーインサチャ
アリエスチャ パティパダ
アタ パーパジャナンコードパッバトワービマッデティ
という偈ですね 意味は
怒りが汝を支配しないように
怒った者に対して怒らないこと
怒りなくね 無心人と非暴力は聖者の生き方である
怒りが山に潰されるように人々を潰すのです
という訳はあんまり良くないね
まあもう一度訳します
マーオーコードアッジャバビ
怒りが来て自分を抑えて支配することはさせないでくださいと
いわゆる怒りに占領されないように自分を守ってくださいということです
怒りが占領者なんですよ
そういうイメージで言ってるの
怒りが占領していると
まあしょうがない はい
搾取ってダメです はい
幸福幸福はダメです 怒りに勝てと
怒りに占領されないように気をつけなさいと
それからマーチャくじったくじたん
人が怒ったんだからって怒るなよと
周りの人が怒ったんだから
じゃあ俺も怒ってやるぞと
こんな動物的な生き方ダメですよと
周りが怒っても自分が怒らないと
みんな怒ってるんだから
私は怒りませんよというふうに気をつけてくださいと
それからアッコード 怒らないこと
アヴィーヒンサ 暴力は全くしないこと
だから本当はアヴィーヒンサっていうのは仏教用語なんです
これはガンディに取られちゃって
ガンディこそヒンドゥー教の神様だと現代のと思われているんですけど
まあそれはどうでもいいことで
アヴィーヒンサっていうのは仏教でよく出ている単語なんです
だから怒らないこととアヴィーヒンサって同じことでしょ
暴力はね なんですかね
ダブってますかね これ解決できますかね
なんかダブってるように気がしない？アッコード
真偽がないこと アヴィーヒンサ
非暴力主義 ダブってないんです
怒らないっていうことは怒らないことなんです
アヴィーヒンサって ヒンサっていうのは
この罰を与えて人を調教するときもあるでしょう
人がいろんな変なことをやったり
悪いことをしたりすると
罰を与えて体罰を決めて
いろんなことで人を育てるでしょ
それなんです 仏教は認めません
刑罰制度は だから刑罰は怒りがなくてもできます
親がへっちゃらで子供にやっちゃうでしょうに
別に子供のことを怒ってないんです
だからこの 時々ね なんとか罰を与えなくちゃいけないケースも出てきますよ
何か何か禁止した方がいいとかね
試験勉強真っ最中なのにゲームやっていると
やっぱりお母さんがゲーム機は取り上げる羽目になっちゃうんですね
それは子供にとっては一種の罰なんですね
はい その時もやっぱり暴力はダメですと
だから罰は完全に消しませんだけど
罰自体も理解の上で暴力にならないものにした方がよろしいのです
はい その 2つは この聖者が推薦する聖者が歩む道だよと
次に帝釈天に言うのは
あとパジャマなん行動
この人々の怒りっていうのは
山が頭の上に落ちたような感じやと潰されますよと
山が山が一つ落ちちゃったら
もう命拾いはできませんでしょ
山が崩れたような感じだよと
怒りが落ちたら ですから
我々もそのたとえで 山
これ山崩れやと 山の麓に生きているんだよと
山の麓に生きているならば
絶対希望しないのは山崩れなんですね
それだけはないようにと
気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
だから帝釈天の政治的発言の中でも
すごくそれがあるんですね
君たちも怒るなよと はい
それからすごい面白いエピソードがあるんです
これも 33点で起きた出来事なんです
ある日 帝釈天の王座に玉座にね
あの醜い鬼が来て座るんです
あの帝釈天には特別な座るところがありますね
あれがかなりでっかいんですけど
誰も座らない そちらにはどんな神も帝釈天だけ
うーん 色も書いてあるんですけど
なんかこの褐色のなんか黄色いと赤いオレンジ色みたいな色の椅子みたいですね
椅子ではなくて石のように見えるんだそうです
でっかい石なんですけど
すごいふわふわしてるんです
まあそれはどうでもいいんですけどね
そこは誰も座りません
人は座るところじゃないんです
あれは 天王が座るところです
そちらに この天界にも存在する権利もない
天界の住民でもない もう鬼の一人が来て
また体がぐいっと曲がっちゃって
ものすごく醜い もう見る限りもう模範的に醜いんです
醜い人といえばこの鬼やというぐらい
来てそちらに座っちゃったんですね
突然  それで全部神々が来て
で 神々の世界ではこうやって暴力できないんで
出て行けとか ぶん殴って追い出すとかね
逮捕するとかね はできないんです
処刑にするとかね 全部道徳的で品格よく解決しなくちゃいけない
だから神々もそうしてきて
すごく非難するんです
こいつは何者かと なぜこの世界に来たんですかと
その上 誰も座らない帝釈天の玉座に座って
あらゆる言葉で非難 侮辱するんですね
普通は霊的な存在の場合
そういう厳しく言われると
さっさと出て行くというのが普通常識なんです
あの 捕まって退場とかできないんです
だから束縛するならば
それもその力で パワーで束縛しなくちゃいけないんですね
それで神々が侮辱すればするほど
こいつはどんどん大きくなるんです
どんどん あの醜く 醜いこと
どんどんさらに醜くなっちゃって
さらに威力を発揮するんです
もうおっかないんですね
多数の神でもげるでしょうね
それで怒鳴るは怒鳴るは怒鳴る
どんどんどんどん さらにさらにすごい威力発揮して
どうだいという感じで
こいつはいるんですね
この鬼が 理由は この鬼が怒りのエネルギーを栄養にしているんです
それなんです 神々 それわからないんです
一生懸命接待しているんです
だから神々の心に起きたこの怒りの波動をね
受け取って受け取って成長するはするは
もう人間の 普通は人間の怒りで生きてますよ
だから この人間のところでうろうろしている霊なんかは
怒り 悲しみ 落ち込みで生きているんです
だからみんな毎日毎日怒りが増えるわ
落ち込みが大きくなるわ
治らないでしょ もう霊に囚われてるんです
で 悪いことだったら ゴロゴロゴロゴロと連続してくるでしょ
なんで悪い感情がどんどん膨張するのかというと
これもしかすると そういう怒り
嫉妬 憎しみを栄養にする何か霊が憑いてるでしょうね
それで帝釈天にこの報告をしたら大変なことになりましたよと
あんた遊んでる場合じゃないんだよと
とんでもない鬼が来てね
あなたの座に座に座ってるんだと
で 我々はね ものすごい我々のやり方で侮辱してね
非難して追い出すをしたんだけど
どんどん力が強くなってますよ
あの優しい楽しい波動で生きている神々はどんどん遠ざかっていくんです
遠くから非難 侮辱すると
さらに威力が発揮 もうちょっと下がっちゃうんです
神々が 神々 どんどんどんどん遠く行っちゃって
こいつはものすごい体でっかくなっちゃって
帝釈天に帝釈天 何のことなく
あの鬼のところに行って土下座して頭死体につけて礼をするんです
そうして私はこの天の天
神々の王である帝釈天でございますと
名前をつけることはものすごい謙虚的なことなんですよ
一回言われただけで 神の力がさっと少なくなっちゃって
体も小さくなっちゃった
で 礼は三回しなくちゃいけないんですよ
もう一度立って また土下座をして
死体を地面につけて 私は神々の王である帝釈天と申します
帝釈天と申しますと また小さくなっちゃって
あいつは 三回目礼をすると消えちゃったんです
それで終わり それで怒りに怒りの鬼に勝っちゃったんです
だから帝釈天が怒らないんですよ
なんか面白くなったでしょ
おそらく なんだこりゃじゃなくて
ここまで座っているということは
大した相当なものだと礼をしなくちゃっていうことでしょう
自分の権力を奪われたとかね
そんな怒りの思考はないんですね
あ これ大したもんですね
この人はと 相当の威力があるんだとかね
認めて礼しますと それだけでそいつは消えちゃったんですね
それから神々にね これはと怒るなよと言った言葉がありまして
そここの言葉があるんだから
経典にこのエピソードを入れてあるんです
はい 次のテーマはこの帝釈天も尊敬する人々はいるんです
天皇の天皇が遊びに行く準備をして
車に乗る前に四方に礼をするんですね
だから天皇車でしょ そこは用意してもらって
さっさと王の王みたいな偉そうに胸を張って車に乗るんじゃなくて
まず一生懸命あちらにこちらに
あちらにこちらに礼をするんです
それで御者の神がわからない
王様は誰に礼をするのかと
で 神々 王たち バラモン
人間があなたに礼をするでしょう
三十三天の神々 山の神々
山という天国の神々 それから四天王の世界の神々
人間 王様たち みんな帝釈天に拝んだり
礼をしたりするでしょうと
じゃああなた誰を拝んでいるんですかと
この霊の世界では この下はわかりますけど
自分より上の次元の存在は知らないんです
人間も人間と人間より次元の低い動物の存在を知ってますけど
上は知らないんです ですから
この御者の神から見れば
みんな自分の王様を拝んでます
何よこりゃと聞いたんですね
マンナマサンディテーヴィッジャ
サッベーブッマチャカッティア
チャッターロチャマハラージャ
ティダッスチャティダサーチャヤサッシーノ
との意味は テーヴィッジャっていうのは
このヴェーダのヴェーダを習じている一番トップグレードのバラモンたちなんです
彼ら 私を拝んでますよと
サンヴェーダを習じているバラモン人の中でも聖なる格を獲得している人々
それからサッベーブッマ
地球に住んでいるどんな生命でも私を拝んでますよと
カッティアっていうのは王家の人々
王たちも神の王を拝んでいます
チャッターロウマハラージャ四天王
が 私に私を拝んでいますと
それからティディサーチャヤサッシーノ
すごい力のあるこの天界の三十三天の神々も私を拝んでいますよと
確かにバラモンたちを敬してんのと
他の者が私を拝む アハンチャシーラサンパンネ チララッタ サマヒテ サッマパッバジテ ワンデ ブラフマチャリヤ パラーヤネ
私は戒律道徳を守り 禅定に達している
梵行に通じて正しく出家して
文章間違いで出家している人々を拝むのです
私はね ちゃんと戒律を守って
瞑想の達人で 梵行っていうのはね
まあ出家生活 梵行というし
清らかな生活っていう意味でね
梵行をやっている人々を拝んでますよと
出家を拝んでますよと
続きあります イエーガハッター プンヤカラ シーラワンター ウパーサカ ダンメーナダーランポーセンティ タンテーナマッサーミ マーターリ
さらに拝む人々はいますよと
また 正しく得た財で家族を養う
道徳を守る徳を積む在家がいます
この在家信者を拝むんですと
大胆でしょ 対策点が真面目に生活している在家の人々を拝んでいるんです
しかし その資格があるんです
戒律を守らないと五戒を守らないと
それから悪いことで家族を養ってはいけません
合法的な収入で家族を養う
それから往生したり 善行為をして徳を積む
毎日のように そういう家族を見て
私はもう拝みますと だから考えたらすごいことでしょ
人間知ってるのは 人間が神を拝む世界でしょ
仏教は神が人間を拝む世界を教えているんです
ブッダ言う通りにやれば
神が君たちのことを拝みますよ
神におねだりする 拝む必要はなくなるんです
それで私は思い出したのは
ヒンドゥー教の神殿を拝んでるスリランカの仏教徒は何やと
これで仏教徒だと言えるのかと
最近書いてる本なんか読んでみたら
私のようなことをやっている人々はまるっきり仏教ではなく
仏教を破壊する者だそうです
大統領を応援することもなく
あの 何といいますか ナショナリズムを応援することもなく
もうスリランカの文化を宣伝することもなく
もう一人瞑想なんか教えて
何やこれはと いうふうな本なんですけど
うん だから 何て言いますか
破門されてます スリランカ仏教会から
それは喜んでいる私は一体何やとわからないんですけど
仏典ではそういうことなんです
だから人類が神を拝んでいますよ
形どうであろうとも 日本人には日本人の神がみがいて拝んでます
各国の連中にはそれぞれ自分が作った神がいて拝んでるんです
地球上で逆を教えるのはブッダだけです
これ言ったら公でね 仏教はどういうふうなひどい目に遭うかと知ってますかね
でも元気でいるんだからね
こんなことを言いつつも
だから それは仏教のすごいところなんです
いつでも理性を語っています
人間なら真面目で生きてみなさいよと
それで話終わりでしょうにと
徳を積んで 五戒を守って生活すれば
もうもうこれ以上悩むことはないだろうよと
知らんことに考えたり悩んだり
あの聖地に行かなくちゃ
あの霊地に行かなくちゃとか
あの人に祈祷してもらわなくちゃとか
あの占い師に占ってもらわなくちゃとか
暇があったら仕事をしなさいと
もうちょっと何か仕事して
家族にもうね もうちょっと美味しいものを食べさせなさいよと
暇があったら余裕良いことをしなさいよと
善行をしなさいよという生き方
仏教はそうさせているのです
結局は対策典の話なんですけど
最終的には神が人間を拝むところで結論に達するなるんです
ものすごいずる賢いやり方でしょ
仏教は 初めての大釈迦の話なんです
で またありますね セッターキラローカスミンイエトゥアンサッカラナマッサシアハンピテーナマッサーミイエナマッサシヴァーサヴァ
下車の神 ヴァーサヴァよ
あなたは確かにこの世で優れている人々を拝むのです
私もあなたが拝んでいる人々を拝みますと
で 下車の神も では私もご一緒に拝みますと
また四方いる一般人をね
お坊さんたちと在家の人々と拝んで
仲良く車に乗って遊びに行ったんです
拝んで食べに行ったんです
はい それからまた私のまとめなんですけど
このキャラはいろいろ使いますからね
このリーダーシップって何ですかと説明する場合は
仏教は大体帝釈天のキャラを使ってます
帝釈天を真似てくださいと
ものすごい完璧なリーダーなんです
怒らない 人のことを心配する
困っている人はもう放っておけない
助ける 親孝行する すごい謙虚
リーダーなのに 謙虚っていうのは
能力は生命様々だからね
ちょっとでも能力ある人と会ったら
すごい謙虚で丁寧で これでリーダーなんです
俺は支配者だぞとかね
お前らは何だとかね はないんです
だからリーダーシップを学ぶ人々は
帝釈天に対する経典やらそのストーリーやらエピソードやら
必ず仏典でなくてもいいんです
仏典にもいろんなエピソードがあります
で そういうものは学ぶんです
学んだらしっかりしたリーダーになるんです
仏教が考える福祉とは何かと具体的に説明するために使用されています
それから福祉とは何かという疑問があったら
帝釈天のキャラを学んだら福祉のやり方があるんです
これ 仏典にはないんですけど
ストーリーとしてありまして
昔々ね この 魔が若者がね
若者のすごい若い時にね
どこかに催し物があって
踊りがあってね これを見ようと言ったんですね
そしたら踊り場ではもう誰も片付いて
ただもうそのまま野暮で空いてるところで踊り始めようとしているんです
人々も集めて ゴミがあるところで
そこまま立ったままでもうずっと踊りだけ見ようとしているんですね
自分のわがままだけで
この若者が自分が立つところを綺麗にしちゃったんです
さっさと掃除して綺麗にしたんです
綺麗に場所をそこでそこで座って
よく座って踊り見ようかなと思っちゃうと
ちょっと他の人が来て
お前どけ うちらに座って何やる？言ったら何のこともなく
はいはいどうぞと で 自分が作った場所をあげて
別な場所をきれいにしちゃったんです
言ったらまた人が来て
何のこともなくお前どきなさい
で その場所を取っちゃったんです
それでその人はもう一つ場所をきれいにするんです
それで なるほど みんな清らかなところで立って気持ちよく踊りみたいだろうと
で 若者でしょう だからほとんどみんな年上でしたかもしれませんし
お前どけと言ったら だいたいまあ我々は文化はね
どきます 文句言いません
今もそうなんですよ 例えば私がすごくいい気持ちのいいところで
椅子持ってきて もうクッションも座布団も入れて
本も持ってきて読もうかなと思ったら
もうちょっとでも年上の人が来て
ちょっとどいてと言ったら
何のこともなく はいはい
どうぞとあげるんです
これ 別にすごいことをやっている気分がないんです
全然何にもなく自然にするんです
向こうはどこへどけて言わなくたっても
どうぞどうぞと その場所は目上の人にあげるんです
だからその生き方だと思いますね
不思議なことでも 腹が立つことでもないんですね
それでこの若者が次の場所を綺麗にするは
次の場所を綺麗にするは
もう全部あの踊りの場所を綺麗にしちゃったんです
踊りは見る暇がなかった
それで彼が気づいたんですね
やっぱりこういうふうなことで
人には役に立つことをしなくちゃいけないんだと
だから人にはいろいろ訳があって
まあ考え方もあってね
別にもう公の場所でしょう
俺が綺麗にしなくする必要はないだろうやとね
思う人もいる このうち清掃車が来てゴミを持っていくんだから
ドカンとね ゴミをポイ捨てする人もいる
それは性格が悪いと言ったっても
その人にはそれは気づかないんですね
はい そういうところでボランティアやるんです
人の欠点 性格の悪いところ
だらしないところを補ってあげて
社会に貢献する 社会全体的にそれで助かります
で 私がいる あの どこでしたっけ？笹塚の方もすごく綺麗です
ゴミがないんです 理由は
あるグループがいるんですよ
おじさん おばさんたちの
みんななんか特別な黄色い色を何かつけて
いろいろ道具を持ってきて
全部綺麗にするんです
すごく仲良しで 仲良しグループで
参加したい人にも参加してくださいと看板があるんですけど
まあ我々住んでいる街を我々で綺麗にしましょうと
だから笹塚のところに行ったり来たりするのは
笹塚の住んでいる人々だけじゃないでしょうね
笹塚と言ったっても もう新宿の次の駅でしょうに
京王線なら ものすごい人々は住んでますし
行ったり来たりはするし
しかし 一部の人々は きちんと綺麗な街を作ってます
だから渋谷区には金はかかりません
ということです それからこのこの曲がった若者が
始めたんですよ もう人々を助けること
特に年寄りがね あちらこちらで自分では何もできなくて
例えば家の掃除できなくなって掃除してあげる
屋根の葉っぱがボロくなっちゃって
雨漏りばっかりするんだけど
もう屋根葺き替えることできない
そこでいいですよ おばさんやってあげますと言って
さっさとやってあげたりする
その仕事 一人でできるわけないでしょう
それで同じ気持ちの仲間もどんどん揃ってきたんです
それで 33人になったんです
だから 33店なんです
そこで井戸を掘ってあげるわ
橋を作ってあげるわ だから村の川を渡る橋だから
何か木を伐採してね ドカンと 2つぐらい倒してあげれば
もう橋ですからね そういうことをやってあげたりとかね
で 森を綺麗にしてあげたり
人々が行くところ 道路をね
石とかなんとかあったら
それを外してあげて平らにしてあげたりとか
それで公の活動をする時は
お祭りとかいろいろ もう神のお祭りやらいろんなことをみんなで総出でやる
その時 このグループが行って
もう一生懸命ボランティアしてあげて
この社会を助けてあげる
そこで怒ったらこれできないんだと
だから怒るなよと みんな何か文句言ったら
それはもう申し訳ないと謝ってくださいと
お前に言ったでしょ？明日来ると言ったのに来なかったでしょ
明日でも今日来ると言ったら来なかった
もし他のことでボランティアで忙しくて行けない場合もあるし
頼んだ人が怒るでしょうね
そういうことでも怒らないで
しっかりボランティアやって
その時の決まり 七つですね
あの七つは 我々グループはね
この七つでやりましょうと
ということで 帝釈生まれ変わって帝釈天
だからその展開 その時誰も見なかった特別展開なんですね
で 現れちゃって そちらで大になったんです
ですから ボランティアの理想のやり方は
まあ帝釈天が手本です
怒らないこと 落ち着くこと
明るいことがいかに大事かと説明する場合は
怒らないと言ったら やっぱり帝釈天が手本になります
ということで それでそればっかりやっている帝釈天がバカだと思いますかね
長部経典に長い長い経典があります
それはサッカパンニャスッタというんですね
サッカってのは帝釈天の質問
ブッダと長い長い難しい真理を質問して対話したものは
長部経典で一番長い経典なんですよ
その長部経典 全部長い
何ページにも及ぶんです
帝釈天ですよ メンキャラは
ということは 相当頭もいい人間なんです
帝釈天は理性のある方でもあります
というふうにキャラなんです
あ 終わったんですね そういうわけで終わったみたいです
どうもありがとうございます
あの 何か今の講演に関してご質問ある方いらっしゃいましたら挙手いただけますか
はい では 前のものの方
まず先に あの  今日はどうもありがとうございました
私は今 中３の女の子の母親です
反抗期真っ盛りでして
私が持つ価値観と真っ向から対立し
早寝早起きしてスポーツに勉強に頑張ってほしいという思いがあるのですが
娘は放課後帰ってくるとパソコンでメールをし
テレビを見 夜遅くまで起きてということで
なかなか自分の思う娘像とはなかなかなってくれなくて
今日も言い合いをしながら出てきたんですけれども
怒らないと怒らない  II を読ませていただいて
怒るということはいけないことだということはわかっているんですけども
なかなか そこができない自分での葛藤があって
そこをどうしたら乗り越えられるのかっていうのを考えています
今 お隣の方に 娘を自分のものだという所有する欲があるから
そういうことになるんではないかななんていうお話もあったんですが
毎日なかなかイライラする日々なんですが
そこを乗り越えるにはどうしたらいいのか
伺いたいんですけれども
お母さんたちにとってはね
初めての経験だから大変だと思いますけど
まあ私なんかは まあ子供を預かったならば
みんな反抗期の子供ばっかしなんですけど
だからそれまた男たちですからね
自分の国では反抗期になってかなりやばい状態になってくる
男たちは何のこともなくズルズルで寺に来るんです
で 扱いは至って簡単ですよ
それから面白いんですよ
また で 何のこともなく
すごいしっかりと成長していくんです
お寺に今 2日 3日 4日いると
まあ両親もなんか我が子が可愛くて寂しくなっちゃって
まあちょこちょことちょっかい出したりしたりしてね
やっぱりまあこれっていうのはやっぱりどうにもならんことですね
母親にしてみれば そんな経験ないんでしょうね
だからまあ この反抗期の子どもたちの面倒を見るプロがいればね
一番便利なんですよ 日本の社会ではそういうシステムもないしね
だから全然簡単 大丈夫なんです
だからそこはちょっと慣れてる人が必要なんですね
反抗期の子どもたちとやりとりすることにね
はい  どうしましょうかね
まず この反抗期となんで言うんですかね
そこで言葉遣いが間違ってます
言葉遣いが間違ったということは
考えが間違っている 考えが間違っているということは
対応も間違っているということなんです
これは反抗期じゃないんです
親に反対しているわけじゃないんです
成長の次の段階に入っているんですよ
大人にならなくちゃいけないということに
で ちっちゃい時はお母さんが心配でたまらんでしょ
子供が それでもよちよち歩くことになったら
あちらに行くわ こちらに行くわ
もうもうもうハラハラするでしょ
あれって反抗期ですかね
だから歩けるようになったら
子供は歩く 何かにぶつかるか
どこに行くか そんなこと知ったことじゃないんです
とにかく歩く そこで電車
駅などで待っていると
ちょこちょこ歩いちゃって
ドッカンとホームから落ちる可能性もありますけど
で 子供はそんな知ったことないんですよ
ちっちゃな子供の場合は歩けるんだから歩くだけなんですね
だからこそちっちゃな子供は歩く練習している
歩けば歩くほど面白い
それでお母さんがしっかり守ったでしょ
反抗期や反抗期やと思わないでね
うちの子はもう歩き出しちゃったんだから
しょうがないじゃん これは
とかね どこにあるて何を取るかわからない
包丁を取るわ もうもうライター取るわとかね
だからそこで親がしっかりと自由にさせて守る
歩かせますけど 行ってはいけないところはちょこっとロックをかけておく
それは子供の手が届かないぐらい
ちょっと高いところにある
そんな感じで小さい時はしっかりやったんですよ
しかし この世間のお母さんたちがこの次のステップ
失敗するんですね それだけのこと
それ 反抗期じゃないんです
ただ 次の成長期に入ってるだけで
だから大人になったら親の話を聞くんじゃなくて
自分で判断して 自分の判断で行動してくっちゃあかんでしょ
その練習しているんです
親から見ればとんでもないことなんですけど
しかし 子供は練習しているんです
次の世代になるために
反抗期終わったら大人でしょ
だから親の育ち方 これに合わせて変えなくちゃいけないんです
もういちいち言ったらあかん
もう終わった その時代は
ああしなさい もう終わり
それはしょっちゅうやったんだからね
それから一番いい方法っていうのは
突然大人にしてあげてください
あんたはもう大人になる
今一人前によくようなったもんだなとかね
もうはちゃめちゃ褒めて大人だと仕立ててください
お母さんがもう何も言いません
もうお母さんの仕事終わりました
もう大人ですからね もう独立して生活できるとか
余計にまだ点も取ってないんだけど
点取ったのごとく あの
何といいますか 仕立ててあげてください
で うまくいくんです もう大人ですからね
どうぞということで そこでどうしてもやばいことをやると
ちっちゃな子供にもやったような感じでね
まああんた大人ですからね
ちょっと考えてよ もういちいちお母さんできないんだからねとかね
間違いをするんですよ
当たり前だからね もうわかってないんだから
ものすごく間違いのことばっかり
もうもうハラハラすることばっかりするかもしれませんだけど
まあその時はまああんた大人なのにね
困ったね これでは とかね
まあ大人はそんなことをやったら困ると思いますけど
とかいう感じで もう態度でいつでも何も言わない
ただアイディア提案するだけで
だから何か嫌でやりたくないと
大人でしょ？あなたはね
もうそんなこと言ってる場合じゃないでしょ
に大人になったらね あれが嫌でこれで嫌で生きていられませんよとかね
もうとにかく大人にするしてあげることがあなたの仕事なんです
だから この次の仕事 自分を変えてください
子供を変える必要はないんです
子供はそれでわがままでいい加減で
夜遅くまで起きていて
それでいいんです で なんかちょっと遠くから見るとすごく可愛いと思いますよ
やること言うこと 何でもおかしくて
何一つまとめれなくて
偉そうに態度だけでっかくて
何もできないくせに これ見て親の心で見るとものすごく面白いんです
私たちはそういう目で見てるんです
大人ぶってるんだけど
何もできんですよ それで手を貸そうと思ったら怒られるんです
じゃあ自分でできるかというとできない
こんな状況なんですよ
だからそれ面白いんですよ
こうすごく可愛いんです
自分でもできないのに手を貸そうとするとすごく怒るし
だからそのまま大人だからねということでね
で 私はだいたいこの反抗期になるちょこちょこと前に大人にしてあげるんです
で その時はいろいろ責任を任せたり
もうあんたもう大人だからこれ頼むよとかね
だいたいはできないしね
知ってますけど やったっても大失敗で
またこっちでやり直さなくちゃいけないの
知ってるんだけど ああ
まあ君はね まあ結構よく大人になっちゃったもんだね
早くも もう全然可愛くもないしね
じゃあまあ大人ですから
これこれやってくださいとかね
しかし その連中ができない悪いにやろうとするんですよ
やろうとすれば そこは素直に褒めてあげる
失敗しても それはなかったことにする
そういうことで まあどんどんどんどん次のステップの成長をね
支えてあげなくちゃいけないんです
反抗期という言葉はおかしいんです
それだったら 赤ちゃんがハイハイするときでも反抗期でしょうに
なんでその時言わないんですかね
なんとか歩き出したところで反抗ばっかりでしょうに
そちら行くなよと言ってる
行ってるんだから それ触るなと言って触ってるんだから
その時はどんなお母さんも反抗期と思わなかったんです
だからうまくいったんです
だから世界はこの反抗期って言葉作っちゃって
頭がイカれて連中が それで子育てがハチャメチャにしているんです
あれは反抗期じゃないんです
自分の子供は親に反抗するわけないでしょうに
子供は一人で筋立てしなくちゃあかんだから
感情の気持ちで見ると
逆らっているように見えますけど
逆らっているわけじゃないんです
ただ 独り立ちしなくちゃいけないし
これは誰のせいでもないでしょうに
そこは優しく見守ってあげることは親の仕事でしょう
だから子供はね あまりにも大胆なことをして
家族の中でなんかちょっと困ったと
まあこいつは大人なんですけど
もう私たちの世界にはちょっとごめんだから
あんたあっち行きなさいとか
そんな感じで冗談でふざけて遊びで
いつでも大人大人っていうことはもうかけてあげなくちゃあかんですよ
もう自分で判断して行動する時期になっちゃったとかね
責任はもう自分でやろうよとかね
夜遅くまでやっちゃって
朝早く起きなくちゃあかんだからといって口を挟んではあかん
知ったことはないやと
あなたは １時半まで遅くまで遊ぶのはあなたの自由ですと
しかし 学校に起きるためには 6時に起きなくちゃいけない
あなたの自由ですという態度を取らなくちゃあかんのです
それが躾なんです 放っておく
勝手にさせる 無視する
できることならやってみようと失敗するんですよ
だから親がそれが我慢できないんですね
それはもう我慢するしかないでしょ
失敗するの当たり前だから １
時半まで起きてたら朝起きないの
もう知ってますよ 大人なら
こいつら知らないんでそれが
それだけ だから自分で自己責任でひどい目に遭ったらどうですかね
でお母さんに文句言って
だってあんた頼まなかったでしょうにと
もう大人だからね 協力必要だったらちゃんと大人らしく頼んでくださいと
頼んでなかったら知ったことじゃないという顔をすなくちゃあかんです
それでご自分も成長しますよ
はい  はい それでは 先ほどこちらの端の方で手を挙げてられた方のお願いいたします
長族今日は本当にどうもありがとうございました
対策での話を聞いて非常に勇気が湧きましたし
あとは怒らないことというのを
私の今後生きていく上でのテーマにしていきたいなというふうな心から思いました
そうは言いながらもですね
2月に非常に怒る事件がありまして
これだけは絶対許せないというようなことがあって
ここ数ヶ月間ですね もう怒りに怒りまくって
心臓が痛くなるしですね
背中も痛くなるしで 怒りっていうのは本当に割に合わないなということをつくづく感じて
慈悲の瞑想をしながらですね
その怒って傷つかない人間の幸せを祈っているうちにですね
だんだん怒りが溶けて
あとは痛みもですね 消えてきて
本当に怒るのは良くないなというのを思いながら
今日の話を聞けたので素晴らしかったんですけども
以前 この講演会のところで長老が怒りというのは無明と結びついていますというお話をされたと思うんですけども
自分が怒っている時にですね
前先生の法で怒りは無明と無明と怒りは無明とつながっている
という話を聞いたんですけども
怒っている時にですね
ここで怒らなきゃ男じゃないとかですね
これは怒って当然だとか
そういうささやきがですね
何度も聞こえてきて で
それに付き合ってですね
怒っているとますます心臓が痛くなったりしてたんですけども
この私にこのささやきかけるですね
邪推っていうんですかね
この怒って当然だとか何とかっていう
これ自体が無明ということなんでしょうか？ちょっと無明ということが意外にわからなくてですね
質問させていただきました
よろしくお願いします
あの世間の話に乗るんじゃないんですよ
ブッダの話に乗った方がいいんです
ブッダが大胆に説かれているんですけど
世間はそんなことは言わないでしょうに
神がお前のことを拝んでるんだよと
世間はどうやって言うんですかね
オバマ大統領言うと思う？あんな原始人には言えない
そんなことは だからオバマはじめノーベル賞を取っている愚か者たちはじめ
もう何言ったって乗らない方がいいんです
私はブッダの話だけに乗って
何の怖いことなく生きてますからね
それで怒らなきゃ男じゃないではなくて
それの反対を取ってください
よくも男のくせに怒ったんだよと
だからあれは気が弱くて芯がなくて
って意味でしょうに だから精神的な女性っていうのはだいたい弱いと思ってるでしょ
自分たちが だからひっちゃりで怒るでしょ
あれがこの怒って怒鳴ったりするのは
女性が武器にしているんです
それはもともとちょっと精神的には肉体的というよりもね
だから怒るのは弱気もののしるしなんです
男のしるしじゃないでしょうに
だから帝釈天の神が王が怒らないんです
弱き者じゃないんです
自分の玉座を汚してるのに礼をするんです
あの態度のでっかさ どうですかね
あれこそ王でしょうに
すごく丁重に しきたりに沿って礼をするの
実は私は だから表面的にやることただち
だから玉座に座ってるんだから一番偉いでしょうに
その人に他の人々は頭を下げなくちゃいけないんだから
何のことなく名前を告げて帝釈天と申しますと
礼をする して勝っちゃったんです
だから他の神々がうちの王は情けないと言える？自分たちみんなこの戦いに負けたのに
王は王らしく勝ってみせたんです
だからまあ これだけ許せないということは
世の中であり得るはずもないんです
どうやってそんな思考が出たんでしょうかとね
あなた個人の問題ではなくてね
大体一般的にこれだけは許せないとか勝手に決めるっていうことは
これ自体愚かでしょ これだけ許せないと言ったっても
この揃ってやったのは人間でしょ
だから人間やることでしょう
世の中で 人間やることはもう全くとんでもないいい加減なことやっていうふうに決まってるでしょうに
これだけ許せないと勝手に決めちゃっても
人間だからもう下手な変なことやっちゃいますよ
そういうことだから それはこれだけ許せないではなくて
まあこれひどいことをやるんだなというふうに理解することでしょうに
あるいは正直に私はまあ何でもまあどんな間違いでもあまり気にしない性格ですけど
本当に申し訳ないんだけど
これはなかなか許して無視することはできませんよと
あんたやってることはと
私としてはもう我慢できなくなってますよと発表すれば
それで済む話なんですよ
時々親たちもね 子供に対してこれだけ絶対許さないといろんなことを決めたりするでしょうね
しかし 子供にとっては本当に唯一な決まるべき道なんですね
で うちの娘も絶対芸能界には入れませんよと決めたりしてね
それで親に逆らって行ったところでも売れちゃったとかね
それから親の親はどんどんのこのこと子供を褒めるんだからかっこ悪いんですよ
結局は だから時々我々は愚かだから
これだけ許せないと思うことはいくらでもありますよ
まあ個人的に私の人生の中でも
周りの人々はね これはどう見たってもおかしいでしょうにと
これはどう見てもやってはいけないことをやっていること
結構やってますよ 私は別にという感じで
知らんという感じでいるんです
まあ気持ちとしては気づいて自分の生き方を直してほしいという気持ちはあるんだけど
全然もうやらない それに怒って雰囲気を壊そうと私はしない
その代わりに知ったことではございませんという態度を取るんです
そいつらと仲良くするとすごく気持ち悪くなるんだから
別に犬とか猫とか ちっちゃな子供たちとか
もうはしゃいで楽しくギャーギャーとと生きているんです
そうなってくると 向こうも自分たちも仲間に入ってほしいなと思ってる
入れてあげない そちらそちらでと
まあ反省しながらどんどん更生するように見えると
自分もやっぱりいくらなんでもうちらは可愛いなと思ったりはするんです
まあそういうことだから
誰の人生の中でもね まあそういうものは起こるんだけど
でもこれだけ許せないと思う自分が何者ですかね
私たちには人に何か期待することはできないでしょう
期待はするんだけど この確実にその人が法則的にそれをやってくれるっていうことはないでしょ
期待はしますけど 人にあれこうしてほしいとかね
こうなってほしいとかね
しかし 必ずそうしなさいというふうにすることはできないんです
逆に期待するものはね
そういうものなんですよ
他のものは別に期待しなくても
例えば自分の子供が大人になってほしい
それだけは期待しますよと
そんな期待なくても大人になりますからね
必然的にそうなるんだから
必然的になることを期待しないでしょ
いくつかの道があったときは
この道を選んでほしいと期待する
だからこれはもうわからないんです
だからこれだけ許さない
これだけは認めないっていうのはね
ありえないんです  そんなところでね
あの まあ無明はだからまあそこはわからないことが無明というでしょう
判断したら判断間違ってるし
悪いとわかってるのにやっちゃうしね
あんたにしたってにも怒ってはいけないと身をもって知ってるのに怒ったでしょうにね
だからそれがもう知っているのにやめられないことが無明なんですよ
はい そういうことです
はい では その前の別の男性の方
お話ありがとうございました
先ほどのお話の中で 中国人の強さが絆にあると
家族の絆があるというふうに言われて
私 中国人の友達がおりまして
すごく理解できるんですけれども
一方でお釈迦様は家族の絆を断って出家をされて修行されたと
それからスッタニパータという本で
人は友達を欲しがることなく孤独に生きなさいということが書かれてますけれども
その絆を大事にするという生き方と
それから絆を断ち切る
それか もしくは孤独に生きるっていうような生き方があるわけですけれども
その絆を大切にするか
それとも孤独に孤独を大事にするのかという
その絆と孤独 どういうふうに捉えていけばいいのかというのを伺えますでしょうか
で 仏教の話はこの 2次構想で二重構想で説かれてますね
世間の幸福と真の幸福というね
世間の幸福っていうのは
まああれは一般論で 誰にでもわかることで
それでも人間はわかってないんですね
真の幸福というのは解脱なんですね
これは出世間なんです
世間とは全く関係ないんです
だから二重構造で教えているんだからね
それは二重構造のことなんです
だから社会で社会人で完成
完璧に生きていきたいと思ったら
お釈迦様の世間コースがあります
人格完成して解脱したいといえば
出世間コースがあります
コース 2つです それでこの
例えば家族を捨てて出家する人が絆を切ってるでしょうかと
切ってないんです それでも家族のことを心配するんです
面倒を見るべき時は面倒を見るんです
アドバイスするべき時はアドバイスするんです
家族と離れて出家したんだからといって
家族がすごく心配して悩んで困った時は
その人のところに行って
こういうことになりましたからと
なんとかしてと言ったら
まあなんとかしますよ
例えば出家した人はやってはいけない
かもしれませんだけど
例えばかなり財産的に困っちゃって
全部家もなくならなくて
まあ昔話で言いましょうか
意外に出家は出家でしっかりと頑張っていて
そこですごい金持ちの人とかね
王様とか知っている 自分の家族がホームレスになっている場合はね
なんのことなく王様のところに王様ちょっとお願いがありますよと
うちの家族はこうなってますよと
なんとかなんとかしてくださいと
言って出ていくんです
で 王様がちゃんと家族の家と財産を与えるでしょうに
だからそこは愛着でうちの家族だからっていうわけでもないんだけど
やっぱり心配はしますよ
人類の心配するとなんて家族のことを心配しないんですかね
だからその二重構造だとわかってなくて
日本ではね 最初にスッタニパータを日本訳しちゃったんだからね
あべこべですよ みんなもう
スッタニパータのこの一人で歩めって教えはね
これはもう一般人に言う話じゃないんで
それは一般人じゃないんです
あれは聖者が自分の心のうちを謳っているんです
それ真似する必要としてもね
できるわけないでしょ
だからこのそれは間違っているわけではないんです
それはもう尊い道であって
尊い道を歩みたければどうぞ歩んでくださいという話なんです
しかし 親の面倒は見たくないわ
俺はとかね 子供を作ったんだけど
知ったことないんだという
基本道徳さえも犯す人にとっては尊い道を歩めないでしょう
だからこの出家するときの家族の束縛から離れるのであって
絆から離れるというわけじゃないんです
束縛から離れるんです
絆はそのままなんです
だからそこら辺 まあ私から見れば全然問題なくてね
日本ではちょっと読み違いしちゃってね
まあちょっと考えすぎになったところで
そうなるだけでね 時々それいいわけにするんですよ
で 仕事はできない 能力がない
我が強くて 仕事に行ったら上司にクタクタ言われるでしょ
我が強くて仕事もできないくせに
何で言われるのか 俺が辞めちゃったとかね
そこで食い物もなくて
そういうもう世界大失敗して
じゃあ俺が出家するぞといらん
こんなのは その連中が
全く見えません 出家したらもう出家世界が壊すんです
世界を壊すんです 自分が微塵も成長しない
だって我の塊でしょ 出家した時点で自分という存在感さえも捨てなくちゃあかんです
だからそういうふうなこともよく起こりますよ
社会で失敗したらお寺があるんだよと
ないんで そんなお寺は
これは勝利の道でしょうに
だから社会で勝利しようと思ったらできるんだけど
自分がベストなゲームを選んだと
このゲームできないんだから
やってもやって負けるんだから
もっと難しいゲームちょうだいっていうのはどういう話ですかね
オセロさえもろくに一回も勝ったことない人は
いきなり将棋やるんだと
それも将棋のなんとか竜
なんとかっていうタイトルありますね
何でしたっけ？え？竜王に挑戦するぞとかね
相手についてこれる？そういうことで
仏道っていうのは勝利者の道なんです
それで幸福は二重構造で説かれていますよ
人類みんな解脱したいと思わないんです
それだったら先にじゃあ生活を成功しなさいと
厳しくこれこれをやってくださいと
それを真面目に仏道歩んで
俗世間で成功を収めてくると
まあいくらやったって
他の話も入ってますからね
いくらやっても無常だから気にするなよとかね
怒るなよとかね あなたの期待通りにいかないんだよとかね
それも言ってるんだからね
お釈迦様は見事にプログラムを組んでいるんです
あんた頑張っても希望通りに行くわけないでしょ
だからそんなことに怒るなよとかね
そういうことを言ってるんだから
もう頑張って成功してるんだけど
まあ結局はこれだけでは物足らないと
ですから 家族に対しても
君たちはこれからしっかりと頑張ってください
私が家族から離れますと
言ったらお寺はどうぞと門を開いてます
それで家族が独りしてしっかり成功の道歩んでいるんだから
この出家した人は家族とは何の関わりも持たない
君どうですかね 今日の仕事は？と聞かない
そこはちゃんと育てているんです
もし問題があったら電話を入れても
こちらにそんなことを電話するなよと
あんた方の問題でしょうにと
で そこで切るんですが
何かあったらちゃんと心配をして手は打ちますよ
出家しても家族の誰かが病気で倒れたらさっさと行きますよ
相手が男性だったらまあかんべんまでする
まあ女性だったらみんなまとめてみんなの喧嘩からくり
いろいろあったっても
それをアドバイスしてちゃんと勘弁するようにさせます
それでもしないんだったら
自分がそこら辺にいる
そうすると 出家した人にとってはすごい
もう断れないんだから
まあ面倒見てあげたりする
看病したりとか そういうふうにやればいいことはちゃんとやりますよ
そんなもんで あまりどぶたはしない
しかし この聖者の心のうちっていうのは
何にも束縛がないんですね
束縛はね あらゆる方面で歌うんですよ
たとえ友達がいるとしたっても
友達の機嫌に合わせなくちゃあかんですよ
人の機嫌に合わせるということは
自分の心の自由がないということなんです
だから 才能経典でミッテスハッジアアヌカンパマーノハッペティアッタンパティバッダチットエータンバヤンサンタウェーペッカマーノエーコーチャレカッガヴィサーナカッ
ポ
ちゃんと説かれています
だから 親しい仲のいい気持ちのいい友達があると
そのその友人に対しては愛着が生まれると
それでその人の気持ち通りに自分が合わせなくちゃいけないんです
それが自由な道には妨げになるんだと
あれは精密に心の聖者の心のうち語っているんです
だから皆様が阿羅漢がどんなものか
ブッダはどんなものか知りたいでしょうに
心の中は それのために読んでください
才能経典は あれ ブッダの心なんですよ
ブッダがその心を持ってこれぐらい活動したんです
人間たるものは自分のことしか考えない
もうなんてクソと同じやと
アッタッチャパンニャアシュチーマヌッサ
すごい厳しい言葉なんです
アッタッチャパンニャーっていうのは
自分のことしか考えられないんです
人間に だからアシュチって
というのはもう糞という意味なんです
クソって意味なんです
いわゆる汚れてるんだと
人類が だからエーコーチャレカッガヴィサーナカッポ
だから一人で行動するんだと
と 説くブッダがどれぐらい人類のために朝から晩まで頑張ったんです
しかし 人類から何か欲しいとはないんです
ブッダにはアッタパンニャーないんです
自分の幸福を願うということはないんです
だから他人の幸福を願うんです
それで説法したんです
だから才能経典の方々ですよ
仏教は世界中に広げたのは
お釈迦様 マハーカッサパ尊者
こういう阿羅漢たちなんです
これが日本でちょっと読み違いするんです
だからそれはこの我々にこれぐらいの心配して
アドバイスした方々はどんな性格なのかと知りたければ
才能経典にあるんです
実は我々はこんな境地が心構えだよと
あんた方からは微塵も何もひと欠片も期待しないよと
しかし あなた方の幸福のためにやるべきことをやりますよと
そちらに束縛は何もないんです
だからこれ経典を読むと腰が抜けるんですけど
私でももうもう説法の種にも掴めないでしょ
だからいくらかの人々は私は知らないと思ってるんですけど
暗記していますけど 結局は
そんなのは しかし 読んだだけでも何かそっとするぐらいすごい偉大なる世界なんですよ
偉大なる精神状態なんです
人間には理解 ものすごい不可能な精神
心の中なんです だから
それでも一回ぐらいでも言っておかなきゃまずいんだから
後輩のために 次の世代のために経典として残しておいたんです
それは我々はブッダの聖者たちの心の中という感じで学んだりしているんです
だから何か言われたら
こちらちょっと気持ち悪くなっちゃって
はい 全部畳んで帰りますとかはないんですよ
だからインターネットで私に悪口言ったっても何の意味もないんです
そんなことでめげるものじゃないんです
ただ 論理的に根拠があって批判するならば
それが勉強しなくちゃいけないとは思ってますけど
一人にもできないんです
根拠があって非難 侮辱することは不可能です
それ読んだところで あ
俺の方が相当進んでるんだと
ちょっともうちょっと態度が強くなっただけ
この連中はもうもうとんでもとんでもない病気だと
これでこの人々の人生どうなるのかと
仏教に興味を持つ人々にさえ
もう行くなよと あれはカルト組織やと言うと
私はあなたはカルトって意味わかるのかい？と聞きたいんです
単語知っただけで使うなよと言いたいところですけど
犬と喧嘩しないでしょ
人間が 犬が吠えたんだからって吠え返さないでしょ
無視するんです だからこの世界からね
微塵も期待しないで活動しなくちゃいけない
言っても理解するのはなかなか理解してくれないということは覚悟の上でやらなくちゃいけない
これ 人間悪いんじゃなくて
人間の情気はそんなもんだよと
あらゆる束縛で途方に暮れてるんだと
人々は だから説法を聞きに来るために来たっても
自分の束縛の世界で生まれたちょっとした悩みを解決してくれというちっぽけな目的で来るんです
この偉大なる世界を理解しようと目的じゃないんです
それは知った上で説法していますよ
だからって説法のレベルダウンはしませんし
ちゃんと真理をそのまま語るし
そういうことで これは私たちが私たちの出家のね
ブッダの教えをね ブッダに説かれたように
世に教えてあげることが自分の仕事だと思っている人々のために
いわゆる私たちのガイドブックなんです
皆様のガイドブックじゃないんです
昔ならもうアクセスさせないんですよ
印刷文化だからね なぜかというと
一番最初に才能経典を読んじゃうとね
もうその時点で仏教を誤解してしまうんです
だって何も教育ない 何も準備がなく読んじゃうとね
まあそういうところで
別にあの まあダブってるわけ
ダブってるんじゃなくて
ぶつかってるわけじゃなくて
それはこの二重構造で幸福を語っています
一つは世間 一つは出世間
ですから出世間だから世間との関係はないんですね
だから出世間の上に上げ上げないと次のステップに行かないでしょ
階段は八あると言ったら
一番目から一気に8番目に行けないでしょ
だから 第一のステップには行ってない人が
ああ どう見たっても一番頂上に行かなくちゃといって
ずっと飛んでいける？いけないんです
だからブッダの時代で加速をするで出家した人々は
みんなもうほとんど失敗者がいないんですよ
お釈迦様は失敗して出家してたんですかね
サイケデリック最高でしたから
これって文句なかったんだから
どれほど期待していたかというと
どれほどみんなもう信頼して期待していたかというと
隠れて逃げていかない限りは出ていけないんですよ
だからまあ まあそんなもんですね
まあ人生失敗して出家した人のケースが
もう思い出せないんですよ
例えば殺人鬼のアングリマーラもね
出家したでしょ あれ 失敗じゃないんです
あの人は もう恐ろしい
たくさんの人を殺したんだから
もう行くところがない私には
じゃあブッダのところに隠れますよって
そんな腰抜けじゃないんです
自分が堂々と言われたことをやると
だから先生にもう神にお供えするために
もう何人か生贄にしてくださいと
千人ですね それでおそらく神の呪文を唱えながら人を殺したでしょう
だから本人にとって人を殺しているんじゃなくて
生贄にしてるんです というか
神にお供えしてるんです
それで数が忘れちゃったんだから
指を切って指を一応置いておいたんです
それは首にかけておかないとね
あちらこちら走り回らないと人殺さないでしょ
だからアングリマーラと言ったし
名前も だから彼から見れば彼が成功者なんです
で 最後に王様が軍隊を持って行ったところで
もうお母さんがこれ困っちゃったと
もうお母さんが旦那さんが王様の小者だからね
第一 だから軍隊を動くんだっていうことは
お父さん言ったんですよ
今度はうちの息子は守れませんと
もう政府は動く 軍隊は動けまったと
言ったら まあお母さんはお母さんだから
子供殺されるのは嫌なんですね
そう 軍隊行く前に私はうちの子だからね
もうそれって隠しますと
決めたところで この人はそうじゃなくて
今日は最後やと あと一人で先生の命令が完了するんだと
今日は誰が来たっても気にしませんと
誰が来たっても気にしません
もう最後ですから 国王が来たって殺す
それでこのおばさんが森に一人で入ると殺されるでしょう
だってちっちゃい時 家で家を出て学校に生活してたんだから
もう大人でしょ？お母さんの顔覚えてないんです
だから家は覚えているんだから
教育終わってから卒業してから家に戻ったところで
大人であってから それでお母さんとお父さんとか知り合いますけど
それもなかったしね だからお釈迦様がやっぱり父親母親を殺したらね
もうどうにもならんやと
いくらなんでもお釈迦様が出て行ったんです
それでお釈迦様 ああ よかった
今日は空いてますよと
走れない坊主ですよと
これが もし馬に乗ってきたら
ちょっと私は走る羽目になったんだけどとかね
最後だから楽ちんで走れない坊主が来て
じゃあ殺してやると 言ったところでなかなかうまくいかないんですね
お釈迦様は走れないんですけど
ものすごい人数使って
ものすごいスピードで移動するんです
この人にはなかなか走っても走っても
それでシャモン止まりなさいよと言うんですね
なんか日本のテレビドラマみたいに待って待って言ってやっても
犯罪で逃げる人は待ってる
待つわけないでしょうに
なんであんな変なことを言うんですか？待ってお前
これから殺しますからと
な だから人間アホですよ
言葉使ったって使い方わかりません
でお釈迦さんに待ってと言ったら
お釈迦様はあのね 私は待ってますけど
お前待ったらどうですかと
言って動くんですね だからそこでちょっとディレンマを出して
この人動いてる 沙門が待っているというし
待っている私は動いているというし
これは何かあるはずですよと
こいつはすごい知識人だからね
あ これ殺す前にこれ勉強しなくちゃと
これどういうことかと
言ったら お前らは輪廻限りなく走るでしょうにと
人を殺したり 怒り 嫉妬
憎しみで 無知で無明で
俗世間の感情で 煩悩で
欲で だからこの人も欲でしょ
一人前になりたいというね
もう優勝で左右なんてかで卒業したいんですね
卒業が完了しないんですね
最後の頼みやっておかない
終わらないと これって欲だろうと
お前にとってはと だからお前らきりがなく走るんだと
私たちは怒りなく 嫉妬なく
憎しみなく 束縛なく つらいなく
これ以上やることないという状態になっているんだ
だから止まってますよと
ったら あ これがすごい世界やと
どうか私は弟子にして教えてください
いいよ それで終わり だからあの人さえも成功者なんです
道がどうであっても あの失敗者は出家していないんです
それであの不可触民族の人々も釈迦様出家させたことがありますね
で それは惨めな人を出家させたことかというと
それと違います このスニータという人がいて
この人々の金持ちの便所を掃除するんですね
だから便所を掃除する人々は
カーストランクの中で一番一番下なんです
だから不可触民族ショードラというカーストの中の中でも低いんです
カーストの中で 彼らが日の出前に
人々は怒る前に 起きる前に金持ちの家に行って
便所を全部掃除しなくちゃいけない
それで全部この町から外へ持っていくんです
汚物を担いで そこで何か米とか何かもらいますね
１日の仕事に そこはもう外に置いておくんです
顔を合わせないんです
もしかすると便所のところに置いておくでしょう
米 １合とかそれぐらいのところ
その人は便所を全部自分の天秤の中に入れて
自分の米とかもらったもの
野菜とか それを持ってもう帰るんです
だからみんな起きる前に街から離れて遠くへ行かなくちゃいけないんです
あの便所ばっかしのあれも担いで
お釈迦様 この人は偉大なる人は察知していて
朝早く起きて 暗いうちに街に出て
この人は町の中で仕事をして
お釈迦様は町に入らない
そんな早くは外ですから
生活するのは そこで何のことなく堂々と歩いているんです
この人ちくっとぶつかったの
もう顔を合わせるようになっちゃった
これやってはいけないことでしょ
カーストのすごい優れた人に顔を合わせちゃうと殴られて殺されます
これは決まり だからこの人はあ
そうか そこのみたいな
しまったと言って そこで街から離れて
穴みたいな まあ水が流れるあれやったんだけど
その中に入り込んで隠れちゃったんです
隠れて顔を合わせないようにした
地面に顔をつけてじーっといるので
お釈迦様は通っていくだろうと
通っていったら またあれ便所を持って帰ればいいんです
お釈迦様は何のことなくそちらに行って
君何やってるの？と 君何やってるのかと
言ったら そのままお釈迦様の顔を見ないで
まあこういうことやと
私はこんな家でこういう仕事をなさってますよと
お前はね こんな惨めな生き方で満足？惨めな生き方で満足？どうだ
出家して修行して心清らかにしたらと
お釈迦様は提案するんです
言ったら このお釈迦様顔を見ないで
実は私も心清らかにすることこそ人間の道だと思ってますけど
私たちには社会には入る権利がないんだと
私たちに教える師匠がいないんだと
ああそう じゃあ私が私の弟子にしますから
一緒に来いと それだけ
そのまま立ち上がって
お釈迦様に出家頂いて
お寺に帰ったんです 帰ってものすごい真剣に修行して
さっさと悟りに達したんです
はい だからあの人失敗者ですかね
じゃないでしょ 自分の仕事をちゃんとやっていたんです
しかし 別な道を見つけたら
その場で仕事辞めちゃったんです
でお釈迦様 ちょっと待ってください
私はこれは片付けてきますよとか
それはないんです で それからお釈迦様はどうどうとみんなの前で
これは偉大なる聖者だよと
これが人間の道やと それから国王はみんなもう頭下げてる
要するに 宮殿にも行く
食事に 国王と宮殿の人々をお世話をするという立場になった
だからそれも失敗のケースがないではないんです
もう一つ もう無理に思い出しちゃうと
もう一つありますけど
ある村人がね すごい貧しいんですよ
自分の財産といえば あるのはクワと土をいじるクワというんですかね
クワ 1本なんです これも大したものじゃないんです
だからクワ 1本ですから
それを持っていって 田んぼを持ってる人に何か仕事はありますかと
いいよ これやってくださいと
そこをやって ちょっと何かもらって
また帰る で また次の日
またクワを持ってまた次の田んぼに行く
これやりながら考えるんで
人生って何やと このクワ 1本で生活して
毎日田んぼを耕してますけど
稲 1本もないんで 自分のものは
稲を育てているのに 自分の米っていうのは手に取るぐらいもない
だからこれで生きていて意味がありますかと
せっかく人間に生まれたんだから
何か別な道があるはずですよ
言ってじゃあ出家しますと
で 出家するんだけど この人がクワを自分の命与えた大事なものだから
大事にどこかに隠しておいて出家するんです
そこで出家して修行すると
まあ修行の世界ば楽じゃないんですね
思うほどうまくいくわけでもないんです
それで苦しみながら修行しながら
ご飯は一応托鉢でもらったりもらわなかったり
いろいろですけど どんどんどんどん
まあ嫌だな この人生はね
毎日托鉢出て 俺は仕事できるでしょうにと
俺にはクワがありますから
あれで結構仕事できますよと言って減速するんです
減速してまたクワを隠したところから取って
また同じ仕事をするんで
またそれ嫌になるんですね
何やこれ でまた出家するんです
で 出家生活がまた厳しくなってきて
嫌になってくると 俺はこんな惨めな生活する必要ない
俺の仕事あるんだからね
職ありますから で またクワを拾ってきて
またこれ 2  3回やんの
4  5  6回やったところで
ものすごくそれが惨めになって
行ったり来たり 行ったり来たり
なんだこれはと 一体なんでこうなるのかと
わかったと このこいつのせいやと
クワ 全部こいつのせいやと
私はそのクワに対する執着を捨ててないんだと
だから人生がいい加減で曖昧で
だらしないのではないか
ですからやりますと言って
広い海に川に行って 真ん中でクワを持って目を閉じてぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる体回して回して回して回して外したんです
目を閉じているんです
もう拾えないんです それで回して回してクワを外した瞬間で
この人が勝ったぞと 歓声を上げた
勝ったぞよと それはみんなびっくりして
あんた何に勝ったと えっ？財産に対する束縛を捨てますと
どんな財産？って言ったら
ボロボロクワですよと
しかし その人にとってはすごい執着でしょ
億万長者は億万に執着する
クワ 1本しか持ってない人
それに執着する 執着する
執着の強度は同じなんです
それで出家したんです
悟ったんです だから 6回も減速したんだから
だらしない失敗者って言えますかと
あの人は いくらかはなんか曖昧なところあったんだけど
やっぱりしっかり まあせいぜいそのケースだけですよ
このだらしない人が出家してうまくいかなかったっていうのはね
まあブッダの時代で話ですからね
まあそういうことで あの
仏教は二十四項相で幸福を唱えて教えているし
そこはまあ まあそういうことで
ちょっと読む時はこれはどうかなということはあります
それから言語の問題で
絆は切れるものではなくてね
出家したんだから 自分の母親はただの婆さんになったってわけじゃないですよ
母親は母親だからね 子供持ってる人は出家したらね
あいつはもうそれっきり私の子供ではありませんと言ったって
遺伝子調べたら子供でしょうに
絆ってのはそういうものであってね
執着はまた別です だから執着を捨てるんです
絆は捨てるか捨てまいかって話にならんもんで
あんなのは だから出家した人もちゃんと絆は大事にします
ということで はい  はい
ありがとうございます
えっと もうだいぶ時間が過ぎてしまいましたので
回向経はこれで終了したいと思います
それでは最後に皆さんで回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に来拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーティヨー エバンジャントー サッバローゴー ウィナッサトゥ マテー バワントアンテラーヨー スケーリー
ガー ユコー バワー バウトゥ サッバマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァター サッバブッダ
ヌバーヴェーナ サッバダンマヌバーヴェーナ サッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティー バワントゥ テ アビワー
ダナシーリスー ニッチャンワッダー パチャヤーノ チャッタールー ダンマワッダンティ アーユワンノー
スカムバラン アーユラーローギャ サンプッティ サッバサンプッティ メーウィチャ アトー ニッバーナ サンプッティ ミナーテー サミッジョトゥ
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
では 長い時間どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]